turned down and
um would have had a fit if we couldn't
record this for him so
on
so now on good morning as chair of the
house Ways and Means Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor is a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
20204 this public meeting is authorized
to meet electronically please note that
there is no physical location to observe
and Len listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursu to
the governor's emergency order however
in accordance with the emergency order I
am confirming that we are a providing
public access the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we're utilizing Zoom for this electronic
meeting all members of committees and
Select Staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through this platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessarily participate in this meeting
by going to the website address or
dialing a phone number in the latest
house or Senate
calendar the providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting we previously gave notice to
the public of the necessary information
for accessing the meeting including how
to access the meeting using Zoom or
telephonically as printed in the house
calendar See providing a mechanism for
the public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access if anyone has a problem
27136 or email
HCS leg. state. n. us
D adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to access the meeting in the
event the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Chris Shay and Jen for are the
meeting hosts Joel Anderson is providing
technical
support this is a revenue update for the
House and Senate ways and needs
committees so that the new legisl can
hit the ground running in
2021 please note that all votes are
taken that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote however
we do not intend to produce an official
Revenue estimate so there will be no
formal
votes let's start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required by the right to no law I will
start with our Senate guests and then
ask that our house committee clerk
representative Malloy do the house Ways
and Means Committee roll
call Senator
felus thank you uh Madam chair Dan felus
at home no one is in the room thank you
muted excuse me uh ludella syndrome I'm
at my home in Manchester and there's no
one in the room thank you Senator
dich good morning everyone I Senator D I
am in my home in Peterboro and no one
else is in the room with me thank you
for coming Senator
Morris Senator Morris I'm in my office
in ainson and no one else is in the room
thank you and Senator GAA I'm at home in
my office alone and delighted to be back
glad to have
you uh representative Malloy could you
call a ways and
means yes I'll I'll do
that representative Ames yes I'm here
and Jeffrey in my home office
alone represented
Carrick I'm at home in Warner and alone
except for my sleeping dog
presented
Southworth hi Tom Southworth alone at
home in
Dover clerk Dennis Malloy alone at home
in
Greenland representative
shamberg uh Tom shamberg here in wilmet
uh my wife is in her office other than
that I'm
Tucker you're muted she
muted she is representative Tucker yes
I'm here in Randolph
bunker representative
bunker not seeing her representative
garlo I'm here in Swansea in my office
alone but my hband might wander through
at time
representative
Griffin I am here in my home in Windam
alone I'm sorry I'm calling for uh
Willis Griffith oh Griffith Griffith
lochman representative Stringham
I am in uh fure Texas I'm here uh there
may be a granddaughter uh squawking by
but uh other than that I'm
alone representative
alme on Susan Aly home in my um office I
guess you'd call it in Lebanon
alone thank you it's the
rooll thank you very much so we have
just three absences that absolutely
terrific you didn't call the Republicans
on that list oh oh you didn't I'm sorry
sorry no it's really easy to forget us
we get along so well no
I I
AP it's been a while I'm out of I'm out
of the uh out of the groove
here list representative
major represent major cannot attend
today but we'll listen representative
Griffin yes I'm here in my home alone in
Olie representative
abrami py here alone in
stratum representative Burns oh he's uh
no longer with no longer
sorry representative de set
good morning I'm here in sail in my home
office
alone representative
Edwards Jess Edwards in Auburn sitting
in my lazy boy my wife will wander by
occasionally to give me fresh
coffee representative burin good morning
everyone I'm in Nottingham New Hampshire
alone in my home
office so what that totally and on
representative Lang I understand is been
added to the committee though he doesn't
seem to show up on the lists but he
doesn't seem to be here either he was he
was aware of it he was the meeting uhuh
so he might show up later
that's
14 in
attendance six
absent thank you that does give us a
quorum
so thank you all very much for coming I
hope everyone's received the documents
for the meeting which are listed at the
LBA website at uh
www.j g n
uslba revenues SL FY
2020 underline 2021 underline
revenues.
aspx we will be discussing with the Dr
this morning and with other agencies
whose revenues may have shown changes
since June in the afternoon after a half
hour break for lunch or at 1 pm
whichever is later Chris Shay from the
LBA will be our guide and J 4 will help
me recognize questions from the
participants you can ask a question or
make a comment by raising your hand at
the bottom of the participants tab Jen
can you bring Lindsay steep Carolyn Le
Melissa Rollins and if there's anyone
else you already have from
Dr welcome thank you very
much good morning Madam chair Lindsay
step commissioner of the Department of
Revenue Administration uh Melissa
Rollins senior financial analyst will be
co-presenting with me today very happy
to be here um I'm going to take just a
moment to share my screen so you can see
uh what we'll be talking through and
again this is the same document was
provided to the LBA I believe was also
shared with all of you so bear with me
okay are you able to see that yes yes
PDF of our presentation okay
perfect so as I said we're happy to be
here today we'll be going through the
larger uh Dr taxes um and Madam chair if
it works for you I might suggest that we
stop at the end of each tax and take any
questions relevant to that tax before we
proceed to the next um just because
you'll see that our conversation will be
very different depending on the taxes
that we're talking about this morning
yes okay thank you that sounds good okay
great um so our estimates were
calculated um based on FAL year 21 plan
um based on currently available data is
data either through October or November
depending on the tax type and we made
our um plan amount or our the plan
amounts based on the expectation and
results that revenues um have been
impacted by the covid pandemic over the
past few months um we gave consideration
different payment types that we've
received with in a tax type the tax
periods for which we are receiving
revenue and how the payments May again
be affected by
covid Lindsay I'm I'm sorry to interrupt
could could you could you bump up the
suggestion there you go that's beautiful
thank
you uh part of it's there thank you was
off screen can everybody mute because I
keep hearing this scratchiness and I
yes the last thing I'll not before I
begin um is that these estimates are
subject to change uh as you may remember
back in may we presented um fiscal year
21 Revenue estimates and you'll see
today that our estimates have changed
significantly um since that time so uh
no promises about what the future will
hold we're doing our best to provide
accurate estimates but obviously as we
discussed last time there's no road map
for uh how this pandemic will impact
revenues and so we're constantly taking
in additional information reviewing the
r that we have received to date and
updating our projections appropriately I
will note um that I was attending a
regional tax administrators conference
um last week or the week before and
spoke with Commissioners for the other
New England and Northeast northeast
states and many mentioned the same
sediment when they originally did their
revenue projections they were projecting
significant shortfalls um and revenues
to date have been um surprising in that
they're performing better than was which
what we originally expected so we're not
alone in this boat um trying to figure
out where revenues are headed um but I
hope that you will take the time to
understand what we've what we talked
through today and obviously provide us
with any feedback if there's other
things that you'd like us to
consider okay moving forward the first
thing I wanted to talk about just to
kind of set the stage is the fiscal 2020
anomalous receivable which is a total of
30. 8 million I wanted to make sure
everyone understood kind of what
produced this or why we have an
anomalous receivable and then what
produced it so as part of the state's
year-end financial reporting which um
the state produces the comprehensive
annual financial report or the caffer
which is our um audited financial
statements revenues that are received um
are converted from a cash basis to an
cruel basis and what that means is we
look at the revenues that we received
during the first 60 days of the new
fiscal year so in our case July and
August we look at July and August
revenues and we determine how much of
those revenues that we' received really
are attributable to underlying activity
in the prior fiscal
year so an easy example for this would
be uh business taxes uh business tax
payers provide quarterly estim estimated
payments if we received an estimated
payment in July that's really for
underlying activity that occurred in
June April May and June of the prior
year which is the prior fiscal year so
we would take that estimate and we would
pull it back to the prior
year we do this every year the amounts
are typically pretty consistent so they
have a pretty minimal impact when you
look from a cash to an acral basis
however in 2020 obviously things need to
be different um so what happened in 2020
um it was most significant in business
taxes and in the interest in dividends
tax as you may remember the federal
government extended the due dates from
April 15th to July
15th here in New Hampshire we extended
our due dates from April 15 to June 15th
and one of the reasons for doing that
was to keep all of the revenue within
the same fiscal year however we did have
a number of taxpayers that still
followed the July 15th date so we
received a fair amount of Revenue for
business taxes and interest in dividends
tax in
July uh which is a large contributor to
the 30.8 million of anomalous receivable
um obviously that is an anomaly that
does not happen every year um and it was
not what we anticipated because as I
said our our date was um moved forward
to
june5 we have some small other anomalous
receivables and these are really just
due to timing issues uh we needed to
provide estimates to the Department of
administrative services in July before
July 15th and so we didn't have all of
the revenues in so our estimates were
slightly off from where the actuals came
in but again really the majority is due
to many taxpayers following the July
15th date this produced the anomalous
receivable so this these amounts will
show in the fiscal year 2020
cafer for revenues they are also showing
in fiscal year 21 Cash basis revenues
because when we look at a cash basis we
reflect the amounts that we receive at
any given time so we have done our
estimates including the anomalous
receivables in fiscal year 21 because
that'll be consistent with what you see
in the revenue Focus because again Cash
basis compared to plan however when we
move to the next step and we can have
this conversation again at that time
when we move move to the next step of
using fiscal year 21 as a base for 22
and 23 we will want to take these
anomalous re receivables out of the
fiscal year 21 amounts before applying
our growth rates for 22 and
23 I know this is probably or could be a
New Concept for a lot of folks so I'll
pause here for a minute and answer any
questions
I I had just a question
commissioner if this was a revenue that
would otherwise been assumed to have
been received um earlier in the year but
just received later in the year um if it
was consistent with being received in
this year why wouldn't we use it uh
potentially as part of the base moving
forward so this is revenue that we would
have had anticipated receiving in F
school year 20 we received it late in 21
but we don't expect it to be late again
so we expect this Revenue to come in
timely in April of this year okay got
ited anomalous receivable we'd
thanks I Al also have a question which
um may actually belong to the com
controller rather than you
on this these 30.8 million will show up
in the cafer for 20 when do they
disappear from the official documents
for
21 so they will show in the cash basis
documents for 21 all the way through and
then we will reverse it and put the new
acral in for the fiscal year 21
cafer so it will only show up when we
get to the the preliminary acral
statement in next June next July correct
thank you linday PAB bramy hi hi um it's
is it true that these are revenues that
were really generated in
2019 profits that's been taxed for both
the business tax and the interest and
dividends correct these would be well
it's a it could be a variety of things
um but especially for amounts that we
received in July as I said those are
likely um extension payments or estimate
payments that would have been due in
April and the date extended to
July right I what I'm getting at is that
a lot of these revenues were generated
preco correct correct yes the underlying
tax period for a lot of them would be
preco um however it could be estimated
pay at the beginning of Co um but
certainly the return or extension
payments would be for um tax year 2019
you okay hearing no other questions we
will move into the specific taxes and
I'm going to turn it over to Melissa to
rentals sure good morning everyone um so
this layout should look pretty similar
to what you've seen before we tried to
keep it pretty consistent from our last
Revenue um estimate presentation we gave
you um we have up top we did produce
ranges this time which you're you're
familiar with us because we typically do
that however I think our last ones we
did not do estimate ranges but because
we're unsure as to where fiscal year 21
could end um based on how the next six
months go we felt like we'd give you
that low and high range like you've seen
in Prior Year's past um the top portion
we have our Dr revised fiscal year 21
estimate ranges low and high and some ex
explanation as to where we got um or how
we got to those those numbers and then
in the next section we have factors to
consider which just give um some bullet
points and high level um notes on what
you might want to factor in when
choosing your Revenue estimates and then
you'll see when we get to the next page
page um or sometimes it's on the same
page we actually show you the breakout
of the adjustments each month compared
to plan um for the high and the low as
well as a chart that um is just sort of
a snippet from the first chart that
Lindsay went went over that shows you
plan and then our high and low estimate
compared to plan so I just wanted to
make you
comfortable with the layout as we get
started because you'll see this through
each text that we go through
and I'm going to sort of bounce around
on the slides um to just what sort of
makes sense on how we go so starting off
with meals and rentals tax um just as a
note the historical breakdown of the
components between the meals and rentals
tax is typically 80% for meals 177% for
rooms and then 3% for motor
vehicles um this tax obviously has been
pretty impacted by covid-19 uh fiscal
year to date we're 35.8 million or
23.3% below
plan and then fiscal year to date um
we're 26.5 million or 18.4 million below
prior year that's as of October that
does not include the November numbers um
what we have so far for no November
we're going to be almost we're probably
somewhere between 14 to 15% below
plan
um as you know covid-19 has had an
effect um a pretty good effect on
selling meals and Rental renting rooms
and renting Motor Vehicles coupled with
unemployment rates um and consumer
confidence we had um sort of the state
shutdown had occurred and has since
opened back up but as you know covid-19
numbers are rising which is obviously
going to impact the wi winter months and
consumer
spending um with this tax we also wanted
to note that um we've seen some shifts
in this tax um especially when we saw
the
shutdown there was a large shift from
sit down restaurants of course those
were were partially closed um internal
or partially closed to people going into
the restaurants so we saw the shift of
fast food to fast food restaurants and
then we saw similar shifts for hotels as
those were opened back up to people um
um staying at camps and Cottages or
during online platforms versus staying
at the big hotels so just some stats for
this tax um for September activity which
was reported in October fast food was up
99.6% um ahead of Prior year so they had
returned to normal and actually exceeded
where they were at um prior to covid uh
restaurant full Services were down 6.4%
compared comp to Prior year um so
obviously they have made some pretty
good gains but they haven't returned
back to normal and then the total food
in Industry which includes the
restaurant and the fast foods are down
4.6% and then looking at the large C the
other large category the hotels um
rental agents so your online platforms
um those are up
86.7% compared to Prior year so that's
that shift that I was was just talking
about whereas hotels just your standard
hotels are down
29.6 um so I think because of the
pandemic people are sort of Shifting how
they are um during sort of their
stations or their vacations um and
probably feeling more comfortable in a
smaller setting than in a large setting
so I just want to give you some
background on that and sort of let you
know where we're at so then I can
discuss the highs and
lows so just ask Could you um send us an
email with those percentages that you
just mentioned sure great thank you um
Alissa it looks like Senator Dee has a
question okay go ahead Senator de uh
thank you commissioner um my my question
is have any of your projections included
the potential cut uh in the meals and
rooms ta rentals tax I know that
uh people are thinking that uh the
elasticity of of restaurant meals is 2.3
so that you know by cutting the tax
you're going to decrease it or uh
increase um the the uh um income uh for
that but um given that the reason well a
uh in the past on the cigarettes we seem
to have found that cutting the tax is
not the same as cutting the price and
and
secondly um if the problem is not the
price but a fear of covid um is is
cutting it going to what what would your
estimate be on whether or not um
lowering the tax rate is going to
increase the
revenues yeah so so just as um an
important note when we do our our
estimates we do it on current law um we
don't factor in proposed um proposed
adjustments to any any bills or taxes so
it's it's a it's a great question um
just to get that out there right up
front this is all based on current law
and not based on any proposed bills that
have come through um I don't have an
answer for you yet on an analysis of how
um the M&R tax rate would would perform
if cut I do know I have heard um heard
it in the news being proposed that don't
think Dr has seen anything yet or has
done a proposal on what M&R tax would
me thank you representative abrami has a
question as
well hey he Melissa how are you good to
have you so um this is I I know the
answer to the question but someone asked
me this the other day I just wanted to
make sure
uh when we're saying when we're talking
plan here and then for all the other
slides that have plan on it we are
talking about the budgeted plan
unadjusted by any of our our other
estimates that we did in in the spring
this is the budgeted number that was
originally adopted correct yes okay I
just wanted to clarify that uh that
point I thought that was the answer but
someone asked me and I said well I don't
think it was adjusted but uh so we're
talking about against the plan that we
we came up with uh almost two years ago
thank you right thank you that's that's
a great question we have done estimates
there's been some numbers put out there
but as of right now the plan is still
the official plan right thank you
sure okay so moving on to Dr revised
fiscal year 21 estimate ranges um
Melissa I'm sorry it looks like
represent Aly wants to get into sorry I
can't see when there's a hand rais so
right and I'm having trouble remembering
which one is with on mute and unmute um
yes and i' I'd heard that too and and
followed it up and just to make sure and
on we are operating on the original ones
I would like to remind everybody that
when we did the original ones at least
when it left the house and I think
partially still after it left the
committee of conference on the we had
programmed in a reduction in activity
for this year on the idea that there
sometime so that the plan is a little
bit lower than it would have been if
we'd been thinking that that the economy
Busters okay any further questions
before I go on or
statements okay
so back to um the low so our low uh
adjustment is 94.6 million or 24% below
plan um these reductions were made based
on past M&R performance um uh really
over the last couple of months they were
also anticipated with seeing deeper
losses in colder months and a slower
recovery as it tends to warm um in the
spring and a vaccine is made more
available um um to the public so in
order to get this low point in revenues
we adjusted revenues to mirror December
through April April which essentially
was what we saw um for August Revenue
which is July activity which is a loss
of
25% with a recovery similar to what we
saw through October and November of 19%
and 177% oh excuse me a loss of 25
negative 25% % um for October and
November and then we sort of decreased
that loss like we said as consumer
confidence gains to a loss of1 19% and
177% for May and June um and again
you'll be able to see this on the next
slide you'll be able to see how these
months sort of trend out so you can see
the comparison each month compared to
low and
high and then for our high point of
where we thought estimates could
potentially fall um again we based this
Revenue over the last month so each
month for M&R we have slowly seen some
gains um from a low of
55% in May which was a loss compared to
Prior year for April activity to um the
best month that we had had was a loss of
11% which was in October um so you could
see had seen some gains so with our high
we trended that out and made it similar
to what we expect to see this month um
so we adjusted Revenue to continue that
15% loss for winter and spring months
which is what we'll see for November and
then we're accelerating that gain to a
10% um loss starting in April so we're
anticipating again in the higher months
that we we're not going to drop much
lower than what we're seeing right now
for activity and then we'll see it pick
up in April as people start to come out
there's a vaccine and people start to
become more comfortable with um
venturing out and staying at hotels and
restaurants again so Lindsay if you want
slide thanks and here you can see that
Trend that we were talking about um in
the first chart is fiscal year the first
half of it is fiscal year 21 actual this
does include the anomalous Revenue so
you can see where the trends
um were going from ative 34% to 25% 17
to 19 and then for fiscal year 21 to
plan um these are our estimates so the
top numbers the 15% for November and
ending at agga 17% for June that's the
low that's what we just spoke about
where we anticipate this month being a
15% % and then dropping down in the
winter months to a bigger loss of - 25%
and then sort of coming back out of it
in May and June equaling a total loss
for the year of negative
24% and then for the meals and rentals
High that's the line below that um again
you can see we keep November at the 15%
but then we sustain that loss through
March not dropping any lower than where
we're at today and then bringing it back
up earlier than our low in April at a
-1% for and continuing that for the rest
of the year to being only a loss of 19%
so that's sort of the fluctuation that
we could see again we're sort of in a
weird time it's hard to totally predict
where um bees are going to go how this
um virus is going to continue to spread
and what consumer activity is going to
look like and then the next chart below
again is um like I stated before is just
uh a portion of the original chart that
Lindsay spoke to that has where fiscal
year 20 was 20 was and then fiscal year
21 what it looks like compared to plan
and then our high and low and what that
number is compared to
plan happy to answer any questions on
this tax before we move on yeah Melissa
I'm don't see how we can get anywhere
near that high uh the November number is
October oober activity we were in Indian
summer during most of October it was
really weird uh it was very nice but on
a lot of people actually came out that
month as the weather continued at least
in my area and uh it ate outside in the
restaurants uh knowing that that was
their last chance to do it for six
months at least and um
then they've all disappeared now that
it's winter again uh into their houses
and are not going to restaurants I think
that December is going to look like you
think it's going to look uh that is the
November activity and I don't see how
through those winter months when people
would have to eat inside the
restaurants um that there's not going to
be more loss
yeah and I think that's that's a good
point representative Elman I think we
took some consideration into that but I
think one point that um I sort of
glossed over that I should note is
something that we did see that was kind
of interesting when they the
stay-at-home orders took place is that I
think we did see restaurants make this
shift pretty quickly and pretty
impressively into being takeout
restaurants that we didn't see before so
I know a lot of restaurants in my area
that were strictly sit in they didn't do
a large takeout business at all has now
made these accommodations to do a better
takeout they've come up with these new
and Innovative you know ideas to have
these boxes or meal preps or um just
these different ideas that were not
present for them um back before covid
started so that might help sustain some
of the loss rather than them completely
shutting down like they like they did in
the earlier months um just just
something to to note yes I was looking
at the Department of Employment Security
numbers and um this one I think was from
a national survey that included New
Hampshire and for small businesses in
Leisure and
Hospitality uh we are still in November
at 51% Revenue
loss though on the
employment as of the 7th of November was
91% of 2019 for restaurants and bars and
97% in
lodging uh so 80 no 87% in
lodging so that um lodging of course is
tax but um
um it does seem difficult to me to get
up to to the high so represent abami has
yeah just have a question Melissa
or or car yeah well anyway so is any has
this been passed by the Restaurant
Association or get get some reaction
from the industry on some of your
assumptions um this is our first
presentation of this okay out to the
public
I say it's something I think Ways and
Means would probably want to
do uh even earlier than better probably
but thank
you although Melissa do you want to
comment on the conversations you have
with the restaurant and Lodging
Association with respect to the
reopening task
force oh sure um good good point Lindsay
um we did do a presentation um for the
reopening task force that Lindsay just
spoke to um the restaurant and Lodging
Association were in attendance um we did
talk
about where we what we have seen and how
quick we dropped down in our April
revenues um like I said to that negative
55% and then how much we have recovered
and how quickly we sort of recovered or
fast we recovered I know we're not back
to normal but it was a lot quicker than
we had
anticipated um and part of that Trend
I'm looking at the sort of what we had
presented part of part of that Trend um
was that we weren't seeing as many
closed restaurants as we thought we were
going to see for um that March through
August time frame um I think most people
thought we were going to see this
massive drop in in restaurants and it
sort of seems like what we had seen and
I I think part part of this was du due
to maybe the Main Street Relief Fund um
the self employment livelihood fund and
some of that government uh stimulus
money is that we saw a drop in their
revenues but it seems like more
restaurants had come back than
anticipated um and when we did do the
presentation um the restaurant
industries were on the phone and they
didn't have any comment for us at that
point based on what we were seeing or
what we were anticipating seeing so they
they did have some idea of what what we
were looking at um again we didn't have
the high and low numbers that we have at
this point but I do think that um
Lindsay has a good point it's important
to note that we didn't see as many
closures that we had um that we thought
we were going to anticipate obviously
we'll keep an eye on that as the months
continue to to grow but it it felt like
New Hampshire was a little bit insulated
compared to what um other states had
seen in terms of um closures in the loss
of activity in the return of activity
for the meals and rentals
thanks any other questions on M&R or are
forward
okay on to the tobacco tax
this might give me oh there we go okay
good we're able to get it all on the
same
screen um so um for the tobacco tax I'll
go through uh everything in a similar
way to Melissa so our breakdown of
Revenue is primarily due to the sale of
cigarette pack stamps so 92% of Revenue
is from cigarette stamps which you'll
see on the bottom of packages of
cigarettes and 8% is from other tobacco
products and that can be um your
ecigarettes now that can be um your
loose tobacco products um things of that
nature so fiscal year to date we are 15
million or
20.4% ahead of
plan um and we are 16.1 million or
22.2% ahead of Prior year the tobacco
tax has been a bit of a shining light
when it comes to revenues um we're
seeing a little bit of an opposite
effect where covid is not resulting in a
decrease of Revenue but instead is
resulting in increased
Revenue um we saw this at the beginning
of the pandemic where it appeared as
though the wholesalers who are
responsible for purchasing the tobacco
tax stamps were kind of stocking up on
stamps I think due to some uncertainty
about what the pandemic was going to
bring were they going to be able to
continue to access the Dr in order to
purchase their stamps so there was a bit
of a stock up um it appears as though
they utilized some of that inventory but
then we've seen them stock up again um
there's a variety of theories out there
um one of which is although smoking is
not uh a good correlation to your
ability to recover from covid um there
are other people saying that given the
stress and anxiety around the pandemic
um that it is not the most conducive
time for folks to decide to quit smoking
either um so we have seen positive stamp
sales there's another point that I would
like to mention which is um the state of
Massachusetts in June baned mentholated
and other flavored tobacco products and
we believe we've seen a pretty
significant increase in Revenue due to
that and again I was speaking to the
commissioner in the state of Rhode
Island and Rhode Island is seeing
similar increases in mentholated and
flavored tobacco tax St sales in their
state as well um so the the increase
that we've seen is consistent with the
timing of the ban in
Massachusetts um and as many of you know
especially those that have been on the
committee for quite some time um New
Hampshire uh has a lot of crossborder
tobacco tax sales if you were to take
our um tobacco tax sales and do a new
per capita rate of smoking based on the
population of New Hampshire it would be
a very staggering amount um we which is
not true um given the lowest have given
the fact that we have the lowest tobacco
tax tax rate um in New England we see a
significant number of crossb sales so we
sell into Massachusetts and other New
England states quite a bit so in order
to produce our ranges um our low is 32.1
million or 16% ahead of plan and this is
based on the numbers continuing to
increase um but but starting to slow
their uh usage of uh tobacco products
this is potentially due to more people
becoming unemployed having less
disposable income also not willing to
venture out or the inability to come
into New Hampshire to purchase their um
tobacco products and then returning to
their home state for instance in
Massachusetts now required to quarantine
if you come into New Hampshire um so
that may have an impact on the tobacco
tax and that's what we're trying to
reflect with our low
amount with our high amount which is
43.6 million or 22 perc ahead of plan
this would be if we continue on the same
path that we're on um people continue to
smoke potentially smoke more continue to
stock up and the crossb sales continue
at the rates that we are currently
seeing so at the uh bottom part of the
page again this is very consistent with
the the layout from the other taxes um
you'll see we anticipate um between a 16
to 25% increase compared to plan um for
the winter months that does slow to 11%
or 20% for the high as we come into the
spring as again we kind of come out of
the pandemic um and hopefully people uh
do start smoking less um and that
produces the 16% ahead of plan versus
the 22% ahead of plan the chart at the
bottom will show you our plan is
20.2 and we are estimating between
233.356
2 44.8 somewhere between 32.1 and 43.6
million ahead of plan we have spent some
time looking at this because as folks
know if you've been on this committee
for a while tobacco tax consistently has
a 3% decrease year-over-year so this is
definitely out of the norm for us to be
seeing an increase in the tobacco tax um
but at this point in time this is what
estimating I'm happy to take any
questions I have a question it's Pat
again so uh you have a sense of how much
is the menal cigarettes I think when we
because usually we go back and look at a
couple years and and mental is the m
Massachusetts gift
again uh is a real anomaly that I mean
it's going to go on forever I guess uh
is to it' be very helpful to get a sense
of how much of the 30 million above
projection or 35 million above
projection is was due to the menthol
cigarettes being bought not being sold
in Massachusetts anymore sure that's a
great point we don't collect that
information at the time that we sell the
stamps but we can out to our wholesalers
um as we come into the next few months
before um doing final Revenue estimates
and get a sense from them what they're
seeing in terms of increases in their
mentholated products happy to thank
you thank you if I could follow up on
that on if they could give us some idea
of how much of these increased sales is
um within 10 miles of the of the
Border
um that that would be a help also I
think because I don't think they're
going to want to come very far into New
Hampshire I do think that despite the
unless they're going to have state
troopers at every road along the border
the PE people are still going to be
coming in from Massachusetts to get them
inol
sure we can try to get some anecdotal
evidence with respect to that in that
case we'd be looking to the retailers to
find out what they're seeing um in terms
of those retailers along the border um
try to get some information with respect
to that as
tax no
Melissa all right so another positive
one we we like these revenues that are
performing well especially during this
time um all right interest in dividends
tax just for a little bit of background
um this tax has some components that
it's made up of for tax year 2018 40% of
this tax was made up of taxable
annuities or actual cash and property
distributions um 38% % was made up of
dividend income 15% was made up of
interest income and 8% is federal tax
exempt um interest income just so you
know when we're looking at different
areas and what we're talking about
that's how the tax is broken down for um
the most completed tax
year so as I said this tax is performing
well uh fiscal year to date we're 20.1
million or
84.5% ahead of plan this is when of
those taxes though however I'd like to
point out um that Lindsay had stated
that has some anomalous um receivable
Revenue in it so about 9.2% of that 20.1
million um is money that should be sort
of tossed back into fiscal year 20 but
even doing so tossing those funds back
you can tell that we're still um up a
fair amount compared to
plan um about 10 million and then so
fiscal year-to date
um ahead of Prior year is 19.8 million
or
82.2% again with that 9.2 million in
there but even taking that out this tax
seems to be doing well I do want to
point out with this tax um for most of
you guys on on ways and means you know
that this tax is sort of all over the
place um if you looked at a 20-year
Trend some of our taxes are very um
linear and they sort of go very smoothly
up or down and this tax sort of has some
big big Peaks and valleys and and can
have some pretty good swings
year-over-year
um this is a tax that again has 38% of
it is made up of some dividend income so
when the stock market is doing well
you'll you'll see some positivity in
this tax which the stock market is doing
well or has been doing well through
through this pandemic um so obviously
this tax has is impacted by that um
right now people tend to have more money
in their bank so that is the interest
income portion of that we do know that
interest rates are low but still the
more money in the bank produces more
interest which produces um more revenue
for us and then as I said uh so far this
tax appears to be unaffected by covid-19
to date um every month it has exceeded
plan it hasn't fallen below plan um yet
so we definitely um took that into
consider ation when we were doing our
highs and lows and facted that
in so looking up to our fiscal year 21
estimate ranges we have a low of 16.4
million or 14% ahead of plan and a high
of 23.8 million or 20% ahead of plan um
as you can see we don't anticipate this
tax falling below plan for the next six
months or any massive
reduction so the way we got to the 16.4
million or 14% ahead of plan um is we
adjusted December through June to be a
negative 4% below plan this equates the
the estimated loss of GDP for the year
of a ne-3 tog -4%
um below prior year and how we sort of
Justified this or looked at it is that
we could see this potential loss for
these months in the final true up of the
fourth quarter estimate payment or these
returns coming through so we have three
of the four estimate payments in already
and we know those have been performing
well what we don't know is what the
January payment um is going to look like
so that's the fourth quarter estimate
payment it could potentially do well
which is what we anticipated in our High
um estimate but there also is we did
want to be cautious um and note that
some some people could now be really
like looking into things and again
shwing up that last quarter estimate
payment so that's where the 3 to 4% loss
came in for the estimate piece of it and
then the other piece of it is obviously
the returns and extension payments that
will be coming in in April um again we
anticipate in our low that there might
be a loss on these returns as taxpayers
um are TR up their their income versus
what they actually reported to us if
they paid um had paid too much or had
requested refunds so again it's we
anticipated a 4% loss um for the
December through June payments in the
low range which still results in a in a
us being ahead of
plan and then for the high which was the
20% of plan we adjusted um November
through June to be 4% ahead of plan um
this equals to about 4% the 4% growth we
saw in September which was the last
estimate payment we've received in the
largest month we had in this current
fiscal year so again that's definitely a
posit uh a possibility where we're going
to end up um but we wanted to make sure
that we didn't get too excited about
this just continuing to grow when we do
know that there could be a possibility
um of it being adjusted for those last
the next six months as the trups start
to happen um Lindsay if you could go to
the next slide Melissa it looks like
Senator de has a question before you go
on
sure oh I can wait till after after she
goes through this okay and this just um
for the visual people this just makes a
little bit more easy to see what we were
were chatting about um for our low um we
have a 0er to 4% for November having
November be flat and then decreasing um
December through June like I spoke about
at that 4% which was matching around the
GDP and then for our high again a 4%
growth every month compared to plan
equaling a 20% growth um compared to
plan at the end of the year versus the
14% growth compared to plan that equates
to ending up our plan would be 11 16.9
133.33
million happy to answer your question
now senator be okay uh thank you Melissa
um so my question is uh given that uh
people can now uh choose to uh
divert uh their taxes into educational
scholarships uh how what is the estimate
for how much of that diversion will be
taking
place um sure that's a good question so
that was implemented where they could
use interest in dividends tax against
the education tax credit um last year or
two two years ago and they could use it
on the last year's return um we did not
I although there was a lot of talk and
some speculation that we were going to
see a large increase um of people
donating to take advantage of the tax
credit especially in the indd area we
have not seen um that large Spike as
anticipated I don't have numbers in
front of me but I do remember um
reporting to the the expenditure
committee on that and it was it was
minimal in terms of um affecting the
revenues thus far I do also administer
that tax at the Department of Revenue
and we have not for this year again have
not seen a large Spike for individual um
taxpayer
donations thank you you're welcome so so
I put my hand up I don't know if you can
represent Edwards has a question
Melissa yes it's representative Edwards
Melissa I appreciate um the question
particularly when you probably hadn't
prepared for the question about the uh
educational donations but would you mind
just um sending us via email your best
quantitative estimate uh when you get a
chance no
hurry sure
absolutely are there any other questions
on I I would like to ask has is there
any research on the relationship between
the dividends paid out in December which
are a very large part of the dividends
and on the stock market I find I'm
always surprised every
down do you mean do we see them
um in the January estimate
payment actually it wouldn't be in our
numbers it would be in research on the
stock Mark economic research on the
stock
market right so are you looking to
understand cor potential correlation
between the stock market and then what's
paid in dividends in December yes
specifically yeah we haven't looked into
that because we don't know the timing
necessarily of when the Dividends are
paid we just have the total amount of
dividends um but if we come across that
in anything that we're doing as part of
our research we'll be sure to uh share
that with you well they do um produce
reports on the amount of dividends paid
by the major corpor operations I
believe
and and I do know as a person that the
dividends all land in
December once they the businesses know
how their years have something like five
or 10% at the most that come any other
time sure yeah if we come across
anything with respect to that we'll be
you okay moving on to the Comm
communication Services
tax so this I think could be a pretty
quick
conversation um CST is performing very
close to plan um we're just about
400,000 or 2.9% below plan for fiscal
year to date and um slightly ahead of
Prior year 200,000 or
1.5% um one thing to note which I might
help to explain why we're below plan but
ahead of Prior year um this is the
second year of VoIP and prepaid calling
cards being taxable we did anticipate
approximately 2.5 million of additional
Revenue in the Surplus statement for
fiscal year 21 um so it looks like maybe
we're just performing slightly below uh
what we anticipated with respect to the
Surplus statement amounts at least to
date
um uh our our estimate here we didn't
feel the need um to produce a range
since we're so close to plan and so
close to PR prior year um so our
estimate is about just under a milion
900,000 or 2% below plan by the end of
the year um we're just continuing this
approximate 2% um loss from plan we're
just projecting that out through the end
of the
year what we think we have going on here
like I said is a potential either
underutilization or vo of VoIP um maybe
as people are not sitting at their
businesses which businesses are very um
large users of VoIP um or we may have
just slightly overestimated the
additional Revenue that would come in
from VoIP and prepaid calling cards and
that being offset obviously by increased
online video usage as we're doing today
online video platforms and the the
taxability relative to those we talked
about that and sent the committee some
information about that um with our prior
presentation so all in all um CST looks
to be just about a million under plan by
the end of the year and again we didn't
feel the need to produce a higher low
change lindsy Could you um remind us
again of what how you tax video
conferencing is it it when I when I pay
my $100 whatever it is a year or when
someone pays $14 a month is that what
the taxes applied
to Melissa may know more specifically I
haven't looked into any of the
individual um providers and any of their
individual returns but to the expect to
the extent that it's two-way
communication that is taxable but I at
least initially don't have an exact
answer to your question and if Melissa
doesn't we can certainly get back to
you yeah I mean the only the minimal
part that I can add is like Lindsay said
we did look into this I think you had a
question for us um I don't know six
months back or so representative alme or
maybe five months back when this started
to verify that it was taxable um and we
did run every everything through audit
to verify that it is taxable and it does
flow through um on these corporations
returns how each of them assess it
whether it's assessed on the bill or
they're just building in I'm I'm unsure
as to that answer so we can try to get
some more information for you on that
thank you Mrs patan um Lindsay or
Melissa either um this this is the
landline tax correct for the most part
correct right and which we know it's
dying uh so I'm sure the part of the
negativity on this is that trying to
figure out you know less and less people
have landlines now we we talk about this
every year and U really don't see any
recovery on that that end so um but it's
you know I'm surprised it's only
negative2 I think we did a pretty good
job with our estimate two years ago you
know we did so I think you guys were
very very good at this so all right but
it's we're dealing with a tax here
that's really uh dying slowly before us
uh I mean there still there still always
be
landlines but you know especially
businesses but I mean I even got rid of
my landline a while ago um but because I
just got junk mail on it so um Jun junk
U yeah voicemails so anyway um but again
we're dealing with a tax that on its own
forget about the
virus uh is is is dying a slow slow
death is that a correct statement
certainly part part of the tax the
landlines as we have all talked about
are certainly decreasing the addition of
VoIP and prepaid calling cards um from
two years ago um is helping to to
bolster that tax um and we did
anticipate and there are amounts in the
Surplus statement for additional revenue
for that and as time goes on we'll see
how those specific um uh
revenue streams perform um but our our
hope I think or our thought is that over
time this will become more stable as
opposed to the decline that we were
you it's uh have Val me again um maybe I
asked this five six months ago too but
on I am I have my land line is a cable
line and a lot of us now have switched
to table as for our phones because it's
part of a package on I drilled down
which took a lot of time into my Comcast
bill uh a few years ago and discovered
that they were out of something like 200
and something dollars a month that they
charge me on I was paying $7 for the the
um phone part of
it they arbitrarily allocate a very
small amount to the phone because that
one gets
taxed and I don't think there's anything
we can do about that but but so those of
us that still have landlines when we're
on cable it's a nothing right and and
you're right they do tend to package
them as part of a package deal cable
internet and phone um and they kind of
throw the phone in there and I wouldn't
I'm not surprised by what you found when
you drilled down that the lowest percent
okay I think we're ready to move on to
tax all right real estate transfer tax
um this one has been performing well um
again we like to throw this in the in
the positive the positive
bucket
um fiscal year to date we are little
over half a million or a little under 1%
ahead of
plan and um fiscal year to date compared
to Prior year were 3 million or 4.8%
ahead of ahead of plan what's important
to note with that even though those
numbers look low is that um we did have
a $5 million transfer um I think in
September um to the affordable housing
fund which was new um this is something
new that was put into statute so
typically that has not happened in Prior
years past so if you added that transfer
that $5 million that we've already taken
out of the revenue back in you know we'd
be 5.6 million ahead of plan or 8
million ahead of Prior year so I just
think that's important to note so you
can see that it is doing better than
just that half a a little over half a
million above
plan um this tax there's been sort of a
lot of press around it people are
watching it because it has been doing
really well um obviously what factors
into the real estate transfer tax is the
availability of Housing and property
values um as those property values
continue to increase obviously the real
estate transfer tax being paid will
increase um same with the amount of
sales that are going through will impact
um how much tax is being paid we do know
that there's top
of there that we have a housing shortage
um and trying to factor in when we'll
feel that effect um has been challenging
but we try to do our best with our high
and low ranges um also with this tax we
know that mortgage interest rates are
being historically low and they seem to
to be continuing that way um there's
this new virtual home sales that I don't
think New Hampshire had really seen
prior to the pandemic um I had set on a
couple conference calls with Realtors
concerning this and it was so
interesting to hear them speak about um
as the pandemic happened they were
quickly throwing together these virtual
home sales and they were talking about
how they were selling these homes to
people coming from Massachusetts and
they were buying homes without even
seeing them they were doing everything
through virtual walkthroughs um and
again just something different that you
wouldn't think of of buying a house
based on what you saw through video
versus actually stepping into the house
um that plays a little bit of a factor
into our Revenue estimates because when
the pandemic first started this was
brand new and um wasn't I think readily
available or widely used whereas as you
fast forward now these five months or so
um this is definitely something that I
think will help reals through the winter
months and sort of keep those home sales
going as restrictions potentially um
come up for out ofate
travel um this OB obviously factors to
consider for this obviously is how is
the recovery of the economy going how is
the unemployment rate going and then
consumer confidence obviously people
think they're not going to keep their
jobs through these winter months or we
think unemployment is going to increase
or decrease that will obviously affect
this tax um again R continues to perform
well with large
gains however um we keep hearing about
this inventory St short um excuse me
shortage uh that we're waiting to see
when this will run out as well as
potentially some stuned construction in
the winter months um might make some
buyers weary of of holding off until
come spring and there's a vaccine we did
put some numbers in here at the bottom
of this factors to consider we often
look at New Hampshire New Hampshire
Association of realators website to sort
of say what they're saying they have a
great every month and every quarter of
what things are looking like um so I
believe this was based on the
October um it was reported in October
based on September sales so they were
saying despite being tightening of
lending standards and high and
employment buyers are out in full force
this fall showing Amazing resilience in
the middle of the pandemic um and then
there are just some stats about new
listing for single family homes were up
88.1%
um pending sales increased almost 40%
for single homes median sale prices were
up 15% for single homes and then the
piece that we were just keep talking
that I was just talking about about the
monthly Supply decreased to
63.2% for single
homes um with this tax this for those of
you that don't know this tax is reported
to us on the 10th of the month so we do
already have November um November
uh so
November for just what the counties
report to us
um this is gross revenue for dollars
wise they were up
22.9% for November and you'll see this
in our um monthly reports that get
emailed at at the end of the month um
but I'm sort of giving you an inside
preview and then Melissa sure represent
questiones yeah thank you I could have
waited till you were finished but that's
fine I've heard from several sources
that high-end properties have been doing
especially well and I wondered if you
had seen that or you just think it's
across the
board um we don't actually see what the
sales are on however I have read that as
well but I have also read that the
quickest turnaround is actually on um
that 200 to
300,000 piece those those houses they
cannot stay on the market sort of those
first time home buyers um or people
downgrading in their homes those are the
that's the market that's going the
quickest right now thank you
sure and then um the last piece that I
just wanted to speak about for um
November R October activity was that
transactions were up 22.1%
um so we keep waiting to see that sort
of decline to show that inventory
inventory shortage um but that hasn't
shown up yet in in what we're what we've
seen so to move back on to our fiscal
estimates um we adjusted this based
on covid-19 and the loss of revenues due
to people what we called hibernating
during the peak months of covid-19 and
the winter months as well as that slow
constru construction that I was just
speaking about and then um that this
spring and December would be a gradual
increase and not the same drastic
increase we saw during the summer months
of this this current year so for our low
thank you Lindsay for for moving on for
the chart it's a little bit easy to
speak easier to speak to um so we have
November plugged in there because
November we already know that we are
ending up um actually we'll probably end
up a little bit higher than that as some
more revenues come in but we're going to
end up somewhere 42 to
46% ahead of plan for November or $6.6
million up so November is a is a pretty
solid number and then we started to do
our estimates based on December through
June um so our low in December like I
said we sort of tampered it down to um a
13%
ahead of plan and then we dropped it
right off for January through June to a
2% ahead of plan and this has to do like
I said with the um slowing down of
construction and an increase of covid-19
and people sort of high rotating like we
spoke to um as well as that inventory um
shortage happening and US sort of
returning back to normal what we were
seeing prior to the pandemic and these
large
increases um and then our
high we adjusted this for a continued
increase in prices again if the price
goes up the r that's paid goes up so
that price that keeps going up every
single month um with these bidding wars
that are occurring we we showed that
that would continue to happen it would
be a slow decrease with November being
the peak um and we'd slowly drop it but
not as much to the low so as you can see
we have the 42% for November which which
we know and then a slow decline to 31%
20 20% down to a 10% for March through
June um ending with 12% ahead of plan so
the plan for this for fiscal year 21 is
158.4 million our low is 168 um which is
99.6% ahead of plan with a high of
1772 which is
18.8% ahead of plan this one's a little
bit tricky but happy to answer any
questions um or thoughts on where you
think this will end up let's that's Pat
again um just want to make sure I
understand the affordable housing fund
is in the plan number or isn't in the
plan number it is in the plan number is
is in the plan number yes it hasn't been
taken out yet correct it was I'm sorry
it was accounted to be taken out because
it's part of a um it's it's part of a
surplus statement item to be taken out
so the 5 million is red removed out of
the
plan okay so it is and then it's is
taken out of and then Chet you there
yep looking at your report from today
and has revenues up 6.1 million for this
um and the plan was 14.4 million does
that that that does or does not
include the affordable housing fund redu
the affordable housing fund has been
backed out is my understanding in the
plan that transfer was made out of the
general fund to the um affordable
housing fund so it's not in your daily
revenue report okay because that was
restricted revenue and accounted for
within the um Surplus statement okay so
is that taken out when we're looking at
actuals is that taken out once somewhere
along the line or is it taken out so
that was T that's taken out when the
plan's developed so when Department of
administrative Services puts the plan
together for the year they consider what
was in house bill one and two and then
they make any adjustments as per the
Surplus statement right and so in the
plan okay so when the revenues come in
what you're saying is the revenues we're
seeing as
actuals are the revenues with that
amount taken out yes yes it's been
carved out already it's it's been
beginning Year let me ask you about the
okay so it's it's an end of the year
adjustment though correct no there's no
endof year adjustment for that that's a
restricted Revenue now so it's not
included in your unrestricted general
fund Revenue representative AB bramy if
I could jump in I think I understand
what you're asking it was a one-time
transfer that happened in September so
um it came out in September and that was
it so going forward when you're looking
every month it's unlike um the oh I'm
forgetting the name of the transfer we
do on a monthly basis lchip it's unlike
lchip which comes out every month the
affordable housing fund came out one
time in in September and then that's it
so when you're looking month to month
when you're looking only at the month of
November you don't have to worry about
it because it only happens in that one
month all right but was it removed from
what we saw coming in in September all
of
it yes yep it came out in in September
so September was actually five million
higher correct and that's what Melissa
pointed out on the previous slide which
for a second when you look at you know
fiscal year to date we're only6 million
ahead of plan or three million ahead of
Prior
year n about a percent ahead of plan
just under 5% ahead of Prior year but
when you look at our ranges we're saying
six to 12% ahead of plan that might seem
a little wonky that's why because when
you if you were to put the 5 million
back in for the affordable housing
transfer we did perform much better in
overall thank
you there's no other questions at this
time no other hands are up so okay
perfect we will move on
to the utility property tax again this
is pretty simple um Melissa drew the
Short Straw uh when we Divi up this
presentation um I have the much more
simpler ta taxes to talk about um so
utility property tax fiscal year to date
were're 900,000 or 8.9% ahead of plan
1.4 million or 14.6% of head of Prior
year we note at the top that this upt at
least to date does not appear to be
significantly impacted by the
co9
pandemic um we do note though that we do
have a negative 10% adjustment that we
are applying to January and to the
remainder of the fiscal year um April
and June where we anticipate estimated
payments coming in and that is due to a
decrease in the estimated values so we
will the Department of Revenue sets the
utility property tax values and we will
be issuing those um at the beginning of
next month taxpayers will true up the
amounts that they have paid to date in
January and they will use these new
values for their estimates in April and
June so because are seeing the decrease
in the values we have adjusted um plan
appropriately and I will show you that
on the next
slide so you will see the minus 10% from
plan January and again in April and June
which results with a 3% reduction from
plan for the year again this is really
just due to the timing of um the new
valuations being issued in the
associated trups so we anticipate the
end of the year to land at 43 million um
which is down
1.2% from plan of
44.2 oh I have a question
sure so so why is that that 10% that's
fairly
large there's a variety of reasons um
one some taxpayers do have some credits
on file which they will utilize um two
there's a lot of economic conditions and
other scenarios that um go into the
values and so those can fluctuate from
year to year um we also have seen in
past years maybe a little bit of an
abnormal increase in values and they're
kind of right sizing at this point so we
see the decrease um as with any year we
could see new property taxable property
come online um so going forward we could
see an increase but the utility property
tax does like I said tend to fluctuate
kind of year-to year based on economic
conditions based on um valuations and
nature could I ask about those credits
um on are they very large relative to
the
tax
um uh I don't have the exact numbers in
my head I don't believe they are very
large with respect to the tax at this
point um as a note utility property tax
overpayments um under statute are not
refundable unless the property ceases to
exist um so they are carry any
overpayments are carried forward as a
credit so if valuations are challenged
and we go through the hearing process
and a new value is either settled on or
determined um through that course um any
credit but it's not like the BET BPT Pro
no no no these would just be due to like
I said fluctuations in the valuations uh
due to the hearings process or any
overpayments that we
received didn't we have a a bill at
representative AB bramy Knows a Lot
About That was supposed to stabilize
these values that's minicipal Municipal
taxing not not state tax the municipal
version of this correct that's a good
point both the state values the utility
properties and the municipalities do as
well um some municipalities use our
values others do not but yes the the
bill that you're referring to that
representative rahma who worked very
hard and long on is related to those
municip
values Senator de has a
question yeah I believe that we had a
bill um that took the boxes out of the
the valuation of the
utilities and um I believe
that uh may be part of what made the
value go down that they were now
considered supplies rather than
equipment I remember that went through
Means did it go through the
legislature
things yeah I I don't recall that either
um Susan yeah I don't think we saw it I
don't think I noticed it I went crawling
stuff I can look into that a little bit
more that's not ringing a bell off the
top of my head either but um we can get
some more
information I have a question now um um
Lindsay uh do you know if the utilities
of slowing down some of their Capital
Improvement projects though because of
the virus uh that's the only random
thing I can think of that would slow um
because of the virus or there they they
now normally replace certain number of
poles or they may replace other things
that increase the value uh of the assets
that that are being
taxed um I I have no reason to even ask
the question that that's the only random
thing I can think of that would um that
that Co would have any any impact on um
maybe especially in the in the peak
months of the virus when we were all
shut down perhaps they were a little
more careful but I I don't know how much
it really impacted these numbers but but
they are we know the utilities do
Improvement projects and that when they
do that the the the assets you know
values go up the property values go up
sure that is a good
point their development um and you know
we look very far into the future about
the projected um you know revenue
streams of these utilities as part of
how we value the property and so um like
I said there's a lot of things that can
go into this and result in small
pretty
big thank
ches
Melissa oh Melissa you're on mute shoot
I clicked it
um do you starting on the next page just
so I can start with the you want to
start on the next page yeah the factors
to consider if you don't mind thank you
so
much okay business taxes
um our heavy
hitter so fiscal year to date we are
38.4 million or
20.7% ahead of plan again as I spoke to
with interest in dividends and Lindsay
spoke to there is a um a fair amount of
anomalous receivable Revenue in here and
that's 18.3 million so even removing
that um we're still 20 million ahead of
plan um fiscal year to date and I just
want to note again this is through
October and do not uh take into
consideration November November Revenue
which I will speak to um in a moment
fiscal year to date for prior Year we're
ahead 44.1 million or
24.5% and again that has that anomalous
receivable um so even removing that out
business taxes are still performing um
well what we looked at when creating our
highs and lows for this is obviously the
effects effect of the covid um pandemic
on business activity as well as
potential for cash flow issues that
could fect the ability to pay um the
unknown is what this what and when this
um federal government stimulus package
the second round will will occur because
we do know that the first round was was
helpful for these businesses with the
PPP in there as well as um the New
Hampshire help that was given with the
Main Street Relief Fund and the self
employment livelihood fund
um we do uh anticipate that
revenues
um might not well we might have to
address this now because of November but
there there is a a small possibility
that they um could not meet
plan or that they could exceed plan um
this is a little bit different than what
we had I think shared with you with our
last revenues because I think we
anticipated quite a nose dive with these
taxes but that has not uh come to come
to fruition at this point
and with this um this thought that we
could exceed plan this is basically due
to September October and November month
to dat revenues performing well against
plan as well as other states um we've
we've spoken with other states in the
conference that Lindsay spoke about and
I had a revenue conference that I went
to and the these other states are also
seeing an increase in their plans um
increase in their revenues compared to
plan for these business taxes as well so
we're not alone and in seeing this trend
um when digging into this data it looks
like our largest taxpayers um have not
been in impacted by this pandemic as we
originally
anticipated um we're
seeing um better performance compared to
last year in home improvement stores
medical Industries um technological
Industries and box stores uh their
return and um estimate and extension
payments are doing are doing pretty well
and are really pushing us to be um ahead
of plan so
far we can stay on this slide I want you
to note that November that's not our
estimate of just guessing that we're
going to be 182% plan ahead of plan um
that's actually what what has happened
um looking at the report that you're
going to get tomorrow um we're going to
be 20.2 million ahead of November's plan
um we do know again this was our large
companies just driving this increase in
payments um that amount obviously is
factored into our
estimates um we don't think that trend
is going to continue with these one-offs
but um we did want to account for it
because we did know that it was
occurring so again um in the fiscal year
21 estimate command to plan you see that
182% and that's what we have um ahead of
plan as of November November
18th so when looking at um analyzing
these estimates we did it similar to how
we had spoke to in our original um
presentation to the last time we were
here which is where we looked at each
individual payment type that we receive
um so return payments extension payments
estimate payments tax notice payments
refunds and we adjusted those compared
to um prior history uh as well as the
effects of where we thought covid-19
would have on those because we're
obviously talking about a couple of tax
years here and it's based on activity
that's delayed on some levels so we
really went down to more of a
um more finite detail when looking at
these types of payment vouchers than we
would have in the past so there's lot of
numbers here um I'm going to go through
feel free to ask any questions at the
end in case it gets confusing um there
isn't much difference to our or there is
really no difference between our low and
our high when it comes to our extension
and return payments and estimate
payments the big adjustments are in the
refunds which I'll speak to but I just
want you to note note
that so first off like I said um we
adjusted November to anticipate amount
of 35 million um for the month plan was
12.4 Million um and this is based on the
revenue received as of November 18th and
then we trended that out for the
remaining month to come up with the 35.5
million so that that number is an
estimate but I think we'll get pretty
close to
that after November we started looking
at each month individually and then
based on those different payment
vouchers that I had just spoke of so for
returns and extension payments um we
anticipated a 3% increase for return and
extension payments compared to plan
which we applied through December and
January so December through January
returns and extension payments we think
those were going to increase by 3%
compared to Prior year this 3% was based
on um the gain that we saw from March 20
through October 20 um compared to Prior
year so those were returns that came in
had already see a g seen a G have seen a
gain and we anticipated that gain
continuing for December through
January this percentage was then reduced
to negative 18% for excuse me that
should say February for February through
June so that is a
heavier heavier loss um but that makes
sense when you think about what we've
seen so far was delayed activity that
wasn't fully affected by covid-19 for
return and extension payments and then
what you're going to see for January
through June are going to be these
returns where most of their activity was
affected by this
pandemic you're going to see our big
months in March and April where the
returns are due and then um some of the
fiscal year filers will continue through
through that point so this negative 18%
where we we came up with that is we we
worked very hard going back and forth um
on trying to find out if we can have any
correlation or find out any Trend to see
um if this covid-19 situation could be
tied to anything we've seen in the past
so we started looking at the prior
recession and I want to note that we
know that this is very different than
the prior recession um but we did see
some similar trends when it came to how
estimate payments and return and
extension payments had performed so what
we did was take what we saw in the prior
um recession and then we made some
adjustments to correlate correlate it to
this economic environment um which
resulted in this negative
18% so that's where we think we'll see
this bigger hit in January through
June after we adjusted the returns and
extensions we took a look at the
estimate payments because again those
are a different animal than returns and
extension payments those are based are
sort of more re can be sort of more
realtime data
um estimates compared to plan were
reduced by 10% for November through
January so that's sort of the last
quarter of the 2020 estimate payments
that we're receiving right now so that
is um full pandemic activity in there
and again that 10% is tied to how um
estimates performed March 2020 through
October 2020 so we just said they're
going to continue to Trend out that have
they they have trended through this
entire
time um we then adjusted that reduction
of 10% to make it 3% below plan for
February through June so we did that for
February through June because now you're
coming into the next set of estimates
for fiscal year 21 and as um this
pandemic starts to an adjust as well as
you know a potential government stimulus
package we may not see that large loss
of 10% it may be reduced down to 3% for
those estimate payments as well as that
percent correlates to we talked about it
with interest and dividends that's the
estimated um GDP loss for the year of
the 3 to 4
per. with tax notices we didn't make any
adjustments to those I think when we
last spoke we had made adjustments to
those because we anticipated um seeing
large losses in tax donce payments based
on taxpayers ability to pay if you look
at our monthly um payment type report
that comes out um you you'll note that
tax notice payments have basically
resumed to normal um and our collection
in audit activity has resumed so we can
assume that those will probably contain
to perform as normal and didn't need
adjustments so what I've stated so far
for our low it's the same factors that
we use for our high so here's the
difference when we we here's the
difference between our low and high it
it comes down to
refunds so refunds for the year were
increased by
45% we essentially increased them by
118% each month through December through
June and made some modifications to them
so what we did is essentially adjusted
them to match last year's refunds and
you know we had a lot of conversation
last year about anomalous refunds and
anomalous payments um
and we know that those anomalous refunds
from last year were were largely from
large corporations and because the large
corporations are driving the increase
this year um it wasn't out of the realm
or out of our you know us anticipating
where we're going to land to think that
that could happen again this year um we
know we saw last year taxpayers making
these large payments and then turned
around and asked for some refunds on
them um so we wanted to put in a factor
that maybe when these returns are filed
in April um March and April that in uh
excuse me January through June because
we have fiscal year filers in there that
they wouldn't be asking for some of
those funds back um so that's our low
range getting us to 17.7 million below
plan or 2% below
plan and then our high range like I said
is basically the same thing that I went
over where with our estimated
adjustments for estimate payments
returns and extensions but we did not
adjust refunds out so we left refunds at
where we anticipate them coming in this
year which is around 44 million which is
anticipated in plan um and that's where
you sort of saw our swing and that's
just with the assumption that what these
taxpayers are paying is they're not
going to ask for this massive refund
back at the end of the year that what
they're paying is pretty true to what
they think they're going to pay and
we're just going to see refunds sort of
settle in as they normally settle in so
all those adjustments that I spoke about
above is where the correlation um comes
down into the chart that Lindsay just
pulled up on the screen where you see
December through June so in December um
you'll see between our high and low
there's only a 1% difference not too big
but then when you look at January um
through June you start to see that that
larger Gap and those are those refunds
being adjusted every month um based on
how refunds are issued out percentage
wise and with all of those adjustments
it ends up with being our low is -2%
below plan and our high is 1% AB above
plan so that gets us
um to can you scroll down just a little
bit further
Lindsay oh thank you I sorry I couldn't
see it on my screen um so the Dr plan or
786.565.4767
92.2 million being 6.1 million um above
plan happy to answer any questions
Melissa representative Edwards has a
question he's been waiting patiently
thank you representative
Edwards hi I was looking at the
difference between your the Dr low and
high estimates for the balance of the
years and it looks like uh it feels like
you have a relatively high confidence
level that that of what you're saying so
so the next so the real question is um
what are the what do you think the odds
are of us hitting that 6% business
profit tax is like less than
10% less than
1% are we GNA get anywhere near that 6%
trigger oops so just to clarify the
trigger is based on fiscal year
20 revenues that will be determined in
the final C that will be released next
month so and again the six% that you're
referring to is for all revenues not
just business tax revenues even though
we're triggering potentially triggering
the rates the 6% is 6% above or 6% below
all re the plan for all revenues at this
point as we spoke to ear the earlier to
this committee we do not anticipate that
there will be a change to the rates but
that won't be determined officially
until the caffer is
released so do you thank you the
correction could you put a put your own
estimate on that there's less than a 10%
chance less than a 1%
chance um I don't have great insight
into all of the accounting adjustments
that go into the Capper but based on our
revenues that we report to the cafer I
would not anticipate that there would be
a rate change thank you very much that's
me sorry I forgot I was not muted just
then um yes that that is already in
stone wherever it is um what I wanted to
ask about was what time period in the
Great Recession were you using we
ratcheted down three times and came
slightly up and then ratcheted down
again during the Great Recession
and
so so I think it would make a difference
to to how you get to
this this loss in the next
year calendar year I can see Lindsay's
looking and I'm trying to pull it up I
believe it was nine to fiscal year nine
to fiscal year
10 okay that's
correct that that sounds like a good
choice to me h
pain okay representative shamberg has a
question and then um abrami and Senator
moris thank you and thank you all for
such a thorough review
uh in looking forward to developing the
next next bium budget if current law on
tax rates is changed downward should
policy makers expect the uh economy to
generate the revenue of the present
estimated plan in a new budget or a new
bium budget just a some kind of take on
this thank
you so are you asking what the potential
impact to rate changes would be on our
Revenue projections for the next
budget yes I believe I am okay um
as I said I I am gonna go out on a limb
and say I'm not anticipating that the um
the rates will change and as Melissa
mentioned earlier we do our Revenue
estimates based on current law um so we
would do estimates based on the law as
it is today and then that's what the
Surplus statement really does is um take
into account those proposed changes um
and reflect them as part of revenues
what we've seen in the past with respect
to fluctuations in the tax rates is that
it is not always the case that lowering
the rate will um be enough to stimulate
so much revenue to necessarily make up
for the rate change but again that can
be hard to kind of dissect because
there's a lot of things going on in the
economy at any given time and there's a
lot of things that impact Revenue so it
can be really hard to come at least from
our perspective to come to a conclusion
a specific conclusion um about the
actual impact of a rate change given
everything that's going on um that
impacts revenues at any given time thank
you
commissioner right representative bramy
has a question Lindsay hi again um
people ask me how business tax are doing
this year and I say pretty good uh but
then I I I always refrain from getting
too excited and I say well we got to
really see what the next quarter Lees
look
like so I hold my breath and say well
the next quarterly is that is that is
that really going to be the point at
which we really know which way that this
is going to go the next quarterly
page I feel like I am always saying well
we'll know more next month we'll know
more next month and I've kind of now I
guess just been resigned to the fact or
gotten used to the fact that we'll know
more but we're never going to totally
know the answer until after it
happen but yes you know we we are
looking obviously to see what happens in
December those will be fourth quarter
estimates for most calendar year
taxpayers that is the time when it is
most likely I think that they will kind
of true up their estimates um because it
is their last estimate payment before
the end of the year so it is the time
when they're most likely to have
evaluated what they've paid to date what
their business looks like to date and
maybe make a more calculated payment
come December um in many cases taxpayers
take their prior year liability divided
by four and make four even quarterly
payments and then we wouldn't see the
impact of that any overpayments there
until we get into return filing season
in March and April okay um I too am
often obviously asked about Revenue
estimates and I am at this point
cautiously
optimistic um I will remind folks if you
haven't taken a look lately refer to our
um business tax triangles in our annual
report that's available on our
website what it will show you is that
the vast majority of our Revenue comes
from a few taxpayers under 500 under 300
depending on how you're looking at it
and I think that this economic downturn
recession whatever you want to call it
as a result of the pandemic as we know
is different from prior recessions that
we've seen but I think one of the ways
that it's most different is that it has
not impacted all businesses evenly you
know prior recessions with just a
general economic downturn all businesses
feel some pain as Melissa mentioned
earlier for every business that we have
that's feeling a large business that we
have that's feeling some pain we have
another one that has you know seen their
revenues explode due to covid so this is
not impacting all businesses the same
way and I think that might be one of the
reasons why we're not seeing the more
traditional down turn in taxes when
we're in a recession um like we've seen
in the past Lindy can I have a follow up
know our unemployment rates come down
pretty nicely actually yeah lower than
than most people
anticipated um what tells me that people
are working obviously there's certain
industries we know hotels restaurants
you know are still hurting uh gyms
things like that but um but the but the
big
taxpayers are generally manufacturers
make things that go into other other
people's products and I haven't heard
any big reports
about uh negative reports about what's
going on in that sector and I think
that's kind of what you you were saying
as well correct that there's really no
indication that those businesses are are
have slowed down um and because it
really it's a supply chain issue with
them because they a lot of our companies
produce stuff that goes into somebody
else's product down down the line
somewhere and I just haven't heard of
any news reports of major slowdowns we
had that in the beginning of the virus
but I I haven't heard lately either so
sure and I one of the recent um graphs
I've seen about the impact of covid and
the potential trajectory of the economy
um looks more like a Nike Swoosh you
know you had that quick drop and a quick
return and then it kind of levels off
for a while and so I think that dip was
just very quick um and short short for a
lot of people but as you mentioned
certainly that's not the case for all
and I don't want to um have anybody
think that I don't think there are
businesses that are hurting because
certainly there are um but as I said
this pandemic is just not impacting
every business exactly the same and you
have the winners and losers um and for
every one of our large companies that
might be a loser there's another winner
that's kind of looking to take their
place in terms of the top taxpayers so
we just haven't had that across the
board decrease in
Revenue thank you
lindsy Senator Morris has a question and
Stringham right and representative elme
thank you for inviting the Senate the um
I I just have a question about are these
numbers accounting for because this is
an easier format than the budget
presentation that's happened for the
last three days um to ask these
questions payroll protection money
accountants are are finally dealing with
companies um in these last two months on
where Washington's looking at payroll
protection and obviously New Hampshire
is going to tax it um has that been
accounted for in these Revenue
estimates that's a good question not
specifically I don't we don't have a
specific number that's an adjustment due
to the taxability of PPP or other Aid it
is just kind of generally accounting for
what we're seeing in um in the broader
economy and in the estimates to date so
I think without PPP other federal aid
other state aid we would see a decrease
in estimates that businesses are paying
um they'd be feeling the pain of the
pandemic potentially more in certain
cases and so with that Aid I think
that's helped bolster their estimates
and keep them at the levels that they
are at so we haven't felt the need to
make a specific adjustment
further
question is there commissioner is there
anyone that tracked the money that came
in well I mean we know what the number
is but is there anyone that's working
with all these businesses that we can
look at this because I I I think it's
significant to be honest with you um in
the uh the fact that most people were
being advised not to take forgiveness
and till later this fall um at an
application process and now they're
finding out um that you know no matter
what there it's going to be considered a
grant and uh I mean I might be
overstating that but um the uh in any
case I think it's a huge revenue for the
State of New Hampshire
but the other thing I would note there
is that um it will be included in you
know gross income um but to the extent
that the PPP money for instance was
spent on expenses that are generally
deductible so you know ordinary business
expenses that are deductible those will
be able to be deducted as well and so
the net impact in that situation you
know if I got a
$100 gonna go into my income but if I
spent that $100 on a deductible expense
you know the net is essentially zero but
if I received that $100 and didn't spend
it and instead invested it or just put
it in my pocket for the next rainy day
then the taxx then that $100 would be
taxable so it's really a business by
business um decision and as you
mentioned with kind of the changing
Federal guidance it's been hard for us
to really kind of get a handle on what
businesses are actually doing but we do
have some great relationships with
accountants and tax preparers and so we
can certainly reach out um to get a
sense of what they're hearing from their
clients yeah commissioner I just think
the $500,000 limits going to be hit by a
lot of small businesses this year which
means they're probably spending it in
New Hampshire um and then on so it's
going to be a multiplier effect and then
on top of all the news that's coming out
of
Washington um you know you're going to
see yearend bonuses that are going to
get accounted for so um I just anyhow I
I would like to see a presentation on
that in Jan January because I think it
sure and we also have a question from
representative Stringham yeah I actually
was uh going to address the same issue
on PPP I think there's 380 billion in
ppps that were uh sent to uh New
Hampshire businesses and who knows maybe
some uh other businesses that have a
portion of their business in New
Hampshire but at at regular tax rates
since a good part of the question has
been answered um uh you know assum
assuming that it doesn't lead to new new
expenditures uh that could be 25 billion
in um uh additional uh business profits
tax or bet Revenue uh in the state kind
of kind of that's the top end uh
ignoring any stimulus effects of the PPP
uh loans uh and and uh soon to be grants
and um um so I was somewhat surprised
that most of the increase is
attributable to the few large taxpayers
and um was wondering if you thought the
PPP part was probably going to be part
of the true up uh that is going on and
and um then you already answered the
question was whether there was any um a
direct effort to account for pppp and in
uh change Revenue uh business tax
revenue estimates thanks I think you
bring up a good point my mind because we
originally estimated business tax
revenues to be much lower than where
they are now my mind for the December
estimates if they are in fact a true up
would be a reduction but you make a good
point that given the additional Guidance
with PPP the true up may be in a in the
positive direction as well um so back to
representative aram's point I won't say
it's the last time I say that we're
looking forward to data from next month
but we're looking forward to data from
next month um to see where revenues will
come in and that will help uh help us
go thank you I don't see any other
questions at the moment I did want to
ask do you have any uh thoughts on what
will happen if we don't get another um
fairly large federal government stimulus
package and the businesses don't get
um we noted the potential for another
stimulus package here as one of the
factors to consider um although how
revenues have been performing to date um
given that there is was EXs PPP funds um
we have had a number of businesses and I
was going to talk about this in a minut
minute um asking about returning their
main street or self- Grant because they
in turn figured out towards the end of
the year that they don't need the money
um I I personally don't believe a lack
of a stimulus package um will have a
dramatic impact on revenues um at this
point in time obviously I think that
partially depends on what happens going
into the winter how long this second
wave lasts and any additional um
restrictions that we see placed on the
economy um but if it's just kind of
status quo for today I'm sure that um
the stimulus package another stimulus
package would be incredibly helpful um
but I think we just kind of have it as
an unknown in our Revenue estimates at
this
point so you're I think assuming no no
such stimulus package we're assuming no
because there is not one um that has
been passed today but it is as Melissa
mentioned something that that we are
thinking about but without a specific
package it's tough for us to um account
for that specifically in our
you okay so there are no other questions
on business taxes I'll just put up the
summary of where we land looking at our
large taxes at the end of the day um if
you combine all the lows low estimates
versus plan would be 56.3 million below
plan at the end of fiscal year 21 if you
take all of our high estimates you'd be
15.9 million ahead of plan at the end of
the fiscal year so this is um a bit of a
larger range um but obviously there's a
lot of unknowns um but hopefully we've
explained thoroughly today um how we
came up with the ranges um and informed
folks to maybe make your own decisions
about where you think we might land
ranges if there are no other questions I
would just like to take a moment to do a
little bit of a Dr plug um since it's
been a while since we've spoken with all
of you we've obviously been quite busy
over the last few months um so covid as
you can imagine for all of us kind of
came out of nowhere um to a little bit
of an extent we transitioned a large
portion of our staff to working from
home we have approxim two-thirds of our
staff that are at home and remain at
home although as Melissa mentioned we
have resumed audit and collection
activities while kind of keeping an eye
to what's going on with the pandemic and
the impact on
businesses um since March there's really
um a few large things that happened here
at Dr the first that I want to mention
is we administered both the Main Street
Relief Fund and the self-employed
livelihood fund so we shifted from
collecting money to handing money out
um the staff did a great job here making
that a pretty seamless transition I'm
really proud of the amount of money um
that we were able to hand out between
those two programs and I know I engaged
with some of you who had some
constituent issues during the time um
that we were doing that so that was a
large undertaking and we were doing that
at the same time we were going live with
our second phase of rims most of you are
probably familiar with rims our Revenue
information management system which is
our roughly 30 million new technology
system our first roll out went live last
fall with the meals and rentals tax
Nursing Facility quality assessment and
the Medicaid enhancement tax and we
actually went live on time um with roll
out 2 at the beginning of October which
includes the business taxes the interest
and dividends tax and the communication
Services tax so that was going to be a
big deal regardless of the pandemic and
the fact that we were all working from
home um but it was even bigger deal
because we were able to pull it off um
seamlessly the roll out has been very
successful we're really excited for it
um we've received great feedback from
businesses and individuals in terms of
utilizing our Granite tax connect
portal um and we're already full steam
ahead on our third and final rollout
which will include all of our remaining
taxes like the real estate transfer tax
tobacco tax Etc and that will go live at
the beginning of August of 2021
so I know it's something that we've
talked about a lot with the both of
these committees over the years so just
wanted to share that positive news um
and that update and happy to answer any
other
questions thank you um I personally have
been using uh the Dr as a model example
for a lot of other agencies and people
in other states I don't think ncsl has
paid enough attention to you um
but it's been absolutely incredible how
well you've made the
transition and I don't know if you're
planning on on continuing to do more
remote work after this we are we do not
have any plans at the moment to return
staff into the office um as you can see
Melissa is working from home um I'm in
the office today but I kind of split my
time between the office and home I
basically come in to sign some paperwork
and things like that um folks have
transitioned very well to working from
home we've been very successful had a
lot of support from doit and we're very
thankful for that um and for the most
part most of the taxpayers are in remote
work situations and so you know for
auditing purposes we're not anticipating
audit travel for a few more months um
but we've been engaging remotely um with
our taxpayers and it's been very
seamless so uh we had little to no
remote work aside from auditing prior to
the pandemic and like I said now we have
over two-thirds to somewhere around
three4 some days of Staff working from
home so it's been um it wasn't easy to
start but uh folks adapted very quickly
and um they've kept up with all of their
work at home and so for the time being I
think the safest place is to have most
staff at home so that's our plan for
going
forward right commissioner Bob G with a
question sure hi Senator good to see you
again uh thank you for all your hard
work and the department and and the good
people working there um looking ahead do
you see this new paradigm of working at
home as potentially becoming a new model
for Dr or perhaps state government um in
some limited or perhaps more expansive
capacity sure I'll speak for Dr um like
I said we had very little um work from
home um which you know obviously
presented its challenges on days were in
the winter where the roads weren't good
um or those of us that are juggling
young families um needing to um care for
young ones or elderly parents whatever
the case may be I think working from
home or the ability to work from home
has shown us that we can uh have a much
better balance of the two um balancing
your home with work I think morale um
has been positive for the most part we
have had a few employees that have
self-identified that working from home
is not for them um and they have asked
to return to the office and we have
allowed those folks to come back in
assuming that they can socially distance
themselves here in the office um I'm
hopeful that we can kind of do a hybrid
approach in the future um I miss seeing
Melissa every day her office is actually
right next to mine and now I only get to
see her on a computer screen so I'd like
to see her in person more often um but I
think now that we have the tools that we
have we utilize Microsoft teams quite a
bit um and the other collaboration tools
that we have I think going forward we
will have much more of a hybrid approach
you thank you very much for this
presentation
it's it's been very helpful and
reassuring uh I hope we'll continue to
April but it's looking it's looking
quite well and I hope you you can
distribute the the answers to the
questions that we gave you to everybody
on the committee the people that are
going to be leaving perhaps if they're
interested we can um can I can send
individually to the Democrats I think
all of the Republicans are back we have
one retiree and one who who lost his
election on
so um this this is looking really
welcome
yes will we be getting copies of this
presentation on we will be getting the
link to it and we all have we all should
have what she's been showing us right
thank you
right and aside from that I think that
that
we're finished rep me this is Chris yes
um I have Lottery available to talk to
the committee now um we need their
time um and I saw the Dr was ending
early so Charlie was graceful enough to
get online and be able to talk to you
now okay okay um and also just to follow
up with if Lindsay provides the question
responses to me we can put on our
website where these documents are
located as well so for those that would
be great that may not be going forward
sure and is that okay to bring Charlie
on board now represent Aly yes uh thank
you all Lindsay and Carolyn and Melissa
thank you very much nice to see all of
you so for lottery we have just a single
page about the the distribution of the
money for the games uh and it's left at
the estimate that he provided uh at the
beginning of the year that was in our in
our
plan as what's likely to come in but I
know there will be questions on Charlie
or
you good afternoon um I think it's
afternoon it is now um certainly um
various portions of our business have
declined and various have grown um most
notably sports betting has increased in
the last month certainly more than we
had anticipated uh obviously the NL
being in play that matters most um one
area we've seen significant decline
that's not just during the pandemic but
prior to that has been the sale of our
jackpot games which is Powerball Mega
Millions and Megabucks uh last year was
a very bad year for us in that area uh
and we had hoped that that decline was
limited to one year
certainly the sale of those products is
declining again this year versus last
year um and while in terms of gross
revenues it's not that significant power
Powerball represents for us it's most
our most profitable product every dollar
of Powerball essentially returns 41
cents of profit to the state so a
decline in that is actually more costly
than other areas uh and so that's why
you get the revenue estimates you do I
try to make this as simple as possible
to break it out by game type
um and as a result you know you have the
numbers you have now like I said sports
betting has increased um Kino also
similarly we're now averaging over
$800,000 a week in Kino sales which puts
us at the level
um around 8 million profitability and
that's why you have the revenue estimate
you do um the rest of them certainly
with the latest transfer we're above
plan um significantly by more than I
think it's $4 million now uh but given
the uncertainty going forward I'm
hesitant to raise guidance if that makes
sense I
this is now no longer the $110 million
is no longer the middle of the road it's
now a conservative estimate um for your
committee and obviously the Senate
committee's um usage and certainly I
know I don't want you folks were
schedule for 12:30 I want to leave time
for questions and happy to answer any
you have as to any of products we
have thank you very much for that sesis
question represent Tucker yes uh I see
that Massachusetts is
considering uh making the gambling uh
Sports gambling legal this year how how
would that affect uh New
Hampshire um it's a good question I from
what I my Intel says that they're going
to wait for next year to pass it um
meaning that they wouldn't pass it until
2021 and then the question becomes in
what form they pass it
um about 80% of our revenues on the
mobile internet side for sports betting
come from New Hampshire
citizens about 50% of our retail give or
take comes from New Hampshire the vast
majority come the the rest comes from
Massachusetts or the vast majority of it
um Seabrook
ER retail which is the physical location
of the former dog track and seab Brook
now called The Brook does about a
million four a week in retail sports
betting the majority of that comes from
Massachusetts um now mind you if there's
that's a different customer somebody
wants to go to retail sports book is a
different customer than someone uses the
phone or the computer
um I think a large portion of that stays
going to the brook only because of the
environment they've created
as well as the likely location would be
the casino at Encore which is a really
difficult place to get to um from North
of
Boston uh the brook is quite easy to get
to from the suburbs that line our
Southern Border in their North the north
of Massachusetts and over Georgetown
Rowley Boxford those wealthy communities
where a almost the majority of our
Revenue at the Rook comes in wages of
$1,000 and
more so those are people walking in with
lots of money who are quite well off um
betting so I wouldn't imagine it would
drop significantly if the mass were to
open it up but it depends on how they
implement it representative if that
didn't realize it was that big over
there yeah so the brook became
representative the brook became the
largest facility for DraftKings in us
right now terms of wagering activity
it's on Pace to do $50 million in
thank you all any further questions
this I noticed that chatable gaming is
still down at three
million that's um that would include
some of what's at the brook wouldn't it
or is that straight Sports beding now
yeah what I suggested to you were
regarding Revenue with straight sports
betting at the brook uh not Char but
gambling uh but although they are up
once again uh $3 million is a
conservative number for childood
gambling for the year they have seen an
uptick with the closure of Encore uh
that Encore um closed their tables um
number of months ago and hasn't reopened
them
oh so Charlie me I mean we got to
players are coming
back yes I I think in large measure um
Encore was a failed experiment um and I
think folks visited a lot of folks in
New Hampshire visited once or twice and
then haven't gone back uh even before
the pandemic their revenues were
declining rapidly um as compared to what
you know they got bullied into building
a $2.4 billion dollar casino that really
would have supported a $900 million
Casino so I don't think they're going to
have an easy time getting players back
after the pandemic is over they're gonna
have to pay for them and pay for them
you follow up Charlie how about scratch
tickets well that's kind of steady or or
that
decline actually our scratch ticket
sales year-over-year are up
18% okay um it's and it's obviously
represents a not quite the majority but
pretty close to the majority of our
revenues um
and have been strong and that's been the
case across the US um for New Hampshire
it's been localized in some areas it's
up very much and some areas it's flat
like for example the Sea Coast is flat
um but the Lakes region is up
25% I would imagine that's a large
measure folks who are staying home and
folks who from Massachusetts now live
here at least live here until the
pandemic is over playing
like we've seen the vacation areas tick
tick up like North Country is up
24% um areas like Conway and Bartlett
and are up significantly um just because
I think there are more Folks up there
waiting out the the
Good interesting what is mobile
internet so that is the the our mobile
platform where you can play Power Mega
Millions and buy e instant scratch
tickets uh that's been growing um
estimates are 10 million for this year
last year I think we're at four million
uh the state
receives the majority of the the revenue
it's 70 some odd percent
um and that's been a growing product a
thank you and I think Lucky for Life is
a Interstate game isn't it it is it's
it's a um a consortion of 21 states
across the US that offer that product uh
you can win a million you can win
thousand dollar a day for life
um and we're in the early stages of uh
expanding that game it looks like next
fall that game will go daily whereas now
it's drawn twice a week and that should
increase
revenues
commensurately like for example we have
on this U one year sheet a game called
Gimme Five which is a state game we
share with Vermont and Maine we went
from three drawings a week to five
drawings a week and saw an increase in
sales more than 30% so it's one of the
sort of given ways we have to increase
sales you know there's only three ways
to make money this and our business
right it's to sell more charge more for
it or spend less uh and so that's one of
those given for us as to you know
Powerball used to be a Weekly Drawing
now twice
weekly next year Powerball will go three
times a week uh Monday Wednesday
Saturday uh and so we expect that to
grow revenues as well uh just another
drawing day for folks to play so that
there's not the time between drawings
does that make it harder
to easier to get well now harder to get
a large Power Ball if you're drawing all
that often it it should have the same
effect I mean this past year has been um
just been bad the jackpot is a function
of two numbers the amount of cash the
group has on hand multiplied by the bond
factor and as you can imagine the bond
Factor has been abysmal because interest
rates are so low
the cash value of the jackpot is almost
the same number as the jackpot I mean
the value of the jackpot so you don't
get these sort of eye popping numbers
like you we would previously uh and
so that's gonna have to tick up a little
bit to help us and a billion dollar
jackpot happens every so often it's like
a three-foot snowstorm I can't predict
it it just shows up and it shows
up so the three drawings hopefully will
increase the number of jackpots of
significance in a given year but the
massive ones are showing up when they
show up it's more likely that it'll
happen in a given year but not a
guarantee certainly and once we jump
with a billion dollar Chasm once we had
jackpots of a billion dollars and more
you know half a billion dollars doesn't
look so interesting anymore which is
remarkable but the case um and we've had
good luck New Hampshire's had three
winners of a jackpot in the last four
years which is statistically ludicrous
uh we had two Powerball winners and one
me
winner um and so that's helped obviously
marketing but we're going to be running
up against the problem with um Powerball
perpetually thank you Char Senator G yes
Senator yeah good to see you thank you
for your presentation are there any
areas of gaming or games of chance that
were not currently engaged in that you
might anticip
exploiting in the future growing our
repertoire I mean certainly there's been
a effort in number of years stor horse
racing uh and there will be I know that
there's an effort again in this next
coming session to sort of introduce that
that would be the largest source of
Revenue going forward available um for
you folks to
you Char Pat again yep you you brought
up an interesting thing I never thought
of it about Powerball and Mega Millions
for instance there there's lost pots of
money that that money doesn't get
invested how does that work is it the
central whoever controls the money is
investing it and how does that how much
how it gets invested so the large pot of
money doesn't happen until the jackpot
win so like New Hampshire for example
twice had winners in the last four
years every St State hangs on to its
money until it's needed to go
someplace so when we have a winner we
tell the winner um yeah great you won
you're G have to wait 10 days because I
need to get 45 States's money first and
that goes through a Clearing House in
Iowa the Multistate Lottery Association
Aggregates all those funds and then
sends them to us and that happens about
a week after they win uh it takes a
while to get that kind of money together
U so the money is kept in State uh in
trust in past efforts some States
governor not New Hampshire thankfully
have tried to grab that money as an IOU
essentially at the end of the fiscal
year to balance a budget Hampshire never
has no we don't want to do
that no literally it happened to West
Virginia once where the governor of West
Virginia grabbed the money in in June
said when the winers you know we'll pay
you next month basically you know to
balance the budget but does the money
get invested though in a conservative
kind of a so we're an overnight rate we
get an interest it's a um a revenue line
on our Revenue item we get interest for
the overnight it's not not much a year
not much right okay yeah I mean State
it's so the hell with the state
treasurers you can imagine and I think
we get credited maybe 200,000 a year for
interest okay all right just curiosity
question that's all thank you not
nothing but it's not me $10 million it's
right okay if there aren't any further
questions thank you Charlie thank you m
members of the house senate good to see
you all look to see you forward we
seeing you
again and we have um 33 minutes until
one o'clock when we said we'd come back
so I guess we're we've got a half hour
lunch hope you're all back again thank
you just so everyone's aware I'm going
to continue the recording I'm just going
to screen share that we'll be back at
1:00 so if you want to stay connected
just mute your um microphone and your
video until you're ready to come back
and if anyone has problems reconnecting
please feel free to reach me by
email see you in a and representative
Aly uh this is representative Ames I
just want to say that I'm not going to
be able to come back after lunch I have
a school funding commission meeting this
afternoon so I'm sorry about that this
has been excellent this morning and
thank you well you will be able to watch
the recording afterwards so thank you
for coming and thank all the Senators I
some of them have dropped off already I
think and um and all of our house
members that
hello
Susan Susan are you
there representative Griffin can you
hear me
yes yes I
can Susan yes I'm here Susan this is
Mary I have a doctor's appointment at 1
o'clock for my eyes may I be excused oh
of
course for coming in the morning thank
you
bye
e
[Music]
this way I can't tell who's here and
but except for those of us that turned
hi
Alan that was a wonderful
morning yes it was yeah on well there's
been a lot happened since we were last
able to do
that well having the um figures on the
terrific yeah I do think it's important
it's hard to look between the computer
and and the figures that you've got and
it's also this afternoon going to be
hard for some people shuffling the
papers to figure out which place we're
[Music]
at represent Aly we can ask the agencies
to um take control of the screen and put
their documents up similar to what
you yeah that would be great that be
wonderful it really makes a tremendous
difference to me I have
trouble because I when I wear glasses
I'm I printed everything out and I wrote
notes in it but I'm the only place in my
house where I can put this setup doesn't
have terribly good
lighting so so when I'm squinting at
something off camera I'm trying to read
so Jerry where are
you
Texas where in Tex Texas is a big state
yeah yeah I'm outside of Houston town
called vulture near Katy Texas
vulture I got a 5 week old granddaughter
here
so a lot of good football players come
out of Katie Texas they sure do a lot of
good baseball players too a lot of
fastball
throwers no
um Roger
Clemens
so when I got down here safe I uh stayed
clear got a negative covid test
and keeping keeping uh keeping safe
distances and and uh from everybody but
my
granddaughter what
is well you're going to have to
quarantine on the way back y on the way
back what is her name Elizabeth
Elizabeth very nice and what are they
calling her Elizabeth so far
y there are a lot of different nicknames
for Elizabeth that was one of my family
names that and Katherine which also has
a lot of variety in it that's a great
name we named our our oldest daughter
sabriel what well that's an unusual
variety but she waited until the the the
ancestor she was named after passed away
so you know there's at least
that
right well I think we ought to get
started it's several minutes past
one and
um Chris Jay is going to have to be
guiding us through who's speaking
um this afternoon I think you wanted us
to start with
Transportation uh starting with
Department of Safety you have Steve
Lavoy and Scott available to speak to
you Steve I think will lead the
me so we just got to
did you hear that that we've asked if
you could put up your
presentation on the
screen Steve you should be in the
unmuted there we
go good
afternoon afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee Steve Lavoy director of
administration for the Department of
Safety um and I'd be happy to uh to
share my screen great for our
presentation
Stevie yes Steve it's
thanks this another of your
students they're all my students she all
my
student I I try to be a good
teacher Stevie was a wonderful
am trying to and not succeeding
[Music]
let me try
right okay well um good afternoon
everyone so again Steve Lavoy director
of administration for the Department of
Safety and uh we'll be speaking today
about the highway fund specifically the
unrestricted Highway fund revenues um
just just a little bit of background um
the department of safety collects um the
vast majority of the revenues for the
highway fund really in two different
areas um one is through the DMV where
all driver related fees from licensing
registrations title um as well as
violations are all recorded um and the
second is through the road toll also
known as the gas tax um both of those
areas have been impacted differently by
covid-19
DMV revenues um have seen a slight
impact but most of the reductions that
we're seeing is really due to timing um
timing because we just don't have the
resources to process uh all the
transactions um as soon as we'd like to
so we expect to see a lot of these
revenues um shift into future years um
and into future months the the gas tax
the road toll is where we do see a
significant decline in revenue and
that's because of declined um usage less
fuel is being used there are less cars
on the road um and we're seeing that
within our our revenues so um the first
screen you're looking at here is the
overall Highway fund as a whole um we'll
go over this briefly and then move into
the major Revenue sources that make up
these amounts so so Mr Lavoy I I don't
know that you're you're scrolling down
all that we're seeing right now is the
title
and it's a beautiful title
page I wanted you to really enjoy it
before I moved on further um how's this
uh that was better The so suspense was
killing me
okay so you see the highway fund Revenue
slide slide number two yes sir very good
so um as you can see in fy20 um there
was a decline in our Highway fund
revenues collected we're about 4.2% less
than planned fy21 we're projecting to
139.3043 less than our plan um and so as
I had already mentioned we we're seeing
declines specifically in U road toll but
also some minor declines and estimates
for our DMV uh revenues
so if we move on to the first DMV
collection Revenue that's registrations
in fy20 um we collected we had an actual
increase in registration revenues in
fy20 for very strong Revenue collections
at the beginning of the year before
covid hit um and we carried those
forward through the end of the year that
we saw a 3% increase over plan but
fy21 um we're not expecting that same
amount we're expecting to go down to pre
uh fy20 levels to fy19 relatively flat
$121,000 decrease um from the plan of 85
million uh we're projecting to collect
5% less in fy21 than our preco levels
for the rest of the year so each month
5% less than pre-co amounts um and uh
that that's what we're expecting for
registration
revenues for motor vehicle operators
Revenue these are your driver licenses
um in fy20 uh we collected about
$726,000 less or 5.5% less than planned
that was a 12.6 million in fy21 we're
projecting to collect 8.48 million in
Revenue um which is uh only $42,000 less
than planned uh this is the area there's
a significant decline in revenues here
this is because of the five-year license
renewal period and so fy21 is our dip
year so we've already projected that um
dip into the amount um but because
individuals need licenses to drive they
uh we still expect to um recover those
revenues and again DMV is working really
hard to make sure that they offer enough
appointments and opportunities for
customers to obtain their driver
licenses even with the new covid
operations that they've put into place
um I do want to take a minute just to uh
let the committee know a little bit
about what DMV's done they've really
worked hard to make sure that they can
continue providing service throughout
covid um they did not shut down um
operations they had to close physical um
appointments and and walk-in Service uh
at the beginning of the pandemic but
they've slowly been building up
appointment-based services for
individuals to come in person for those
transactions that they have to complete
in person um and they've really done a
great job of ensuring that we're still
collecting Revenue during this period of
time um a lot of other states closed
their DMV operations um New Hampshire
didn't and and that's really helped us
out as far as maintaining revenues
fund motor vehicle title revenue is the
next slide slide five in fy20 uh we
collected 9.5 million which is about a
1.7% less than planed of 9.7 for fy21
we're projecting to collect 9.5 again uh
which is 2.7% less than planned and this
projection is assuming a 10% decrease
through April um and then a 5% decrease
in May and June assuming that as we get
through the worst of the winter and into
the springtime hopefully if there's a
vaccine out there people start um
getting some economic recovery going
that there might be some more um
happen motor vehicle inspection C
Revenue this is an area that's
relatively flat we haven't seen a lot a
huge impact from Co um again the laws
haven't been Chang you still need to
have a motor vehicle safety inspection
conducted each year um and so you see
the revenues reflect that and fy20 we
collected $4 million um which was
288,000 more than planned and in fy21
we're projecting to collect $3.8 million
which is
$22,000 uh more than plan which is a
5.6% increase um so not a lot to really
discuss here this is an area that um
Co miscellaneous fees so there's a
couple of changes that you'll see here
the first clearly are the blue uh bars
which are plea by mail so in the last
budget um in the
fy2 uh yeah FY 2021 budget um Bal budget
ple by revenues were moved from the
general fund to the highway fund and so
that's why you're seeing them reflected
for the first time here we bu mail and
motor vehicle fines um which are from
the judicial branch they're related um
so these are fees uh these are fines
related to motor vehicle violations and
an individual if you receive a ticket
you have an option of either paying that
ticket by mail cleaning by mail that
gets processed at the DMV and recorded
directly into the highway fund now um or
you could contest that ticket in which
case you would go to the courts and um
through the court process your fine
would either be upheld dismissed or
maybe reduced and those revenues are
collected through the judicial branch so
for fy20 um f by mail collections were
$5.6 million which was less than planned
uh about 33.3% less in fy21 we're
projecting $7.5 million in ple by mail
collections Which is 10.7% less than
plan
and then the judicial branch fines
through the courts we collected 4.7
million in fy20 which was an 11.4%
decrease from plan and in fy21 we're
projecting 4.3 million which is $640,000
of less than the plan the current plan
amount being 4.9 million and those are
amounts that we um that that we work
with um with with the AOC on obtaining
making sure that we understand what the
court system looks like like how how are
they able to process especially with
covid-19 um so those are the revised
estimates that they helped uh provide to
us um the big decline in in violations
here has to do with um a decline in
traffic that we saw so when the when the
pandemic first hit um there were not as
many cars on the road um and um so
therefore there were not as many tickets
that were written um as things started
to progress and more vehicles uh became
present we had more people coming into
the state um enforcement efforts were
also uh increased and so there were more
tickets that were being written uh and
that's why there's an increase in
forward so then unrestricted road toll
revenues um this is again this is the
big area that I mentioned before that's
really been impacted by
covid-19 um so we'll go over the number
and then we can talk a little bit about
why we're thinking this is where we're
going to land uh in
fy20 you can see we collected
$19.8 million which is an 8% decrease
over plan so we're over $10 million
short uh from our planned amount in fy21
we're projecting to collect $117 million
uh which is an
11.5% decline from the plan of
132 um
the the declines have to do with um the
the volume of traffic that we're seeing
on the roads so typically when we talk
about road toll um I know when I've
talked to this group in the past we talk
about price we talk about weather we
talk about economy and so those are the
three factors that we would consider
When developing our our plans right now
the price for um for gasoline is is low
price is not really an issue
um we we've got
a199 is the average in the state you'll
see it lower uh in some places you'll
see it over $2 and others but um it's
$1.99 is is the average currently and um
we're expecting the price of a gallon to
go down before the end of the year this
is from the um the US Energy Information
Administration the eia they forecast gas
prices we're expected to decline across
the US to 1.9 a193 a gallon um and then
in 2021 by the end of 2021 increased to
$217 a gallon either way those are low
prices especially if you go back the
last maybe five to eight years or so um
so price is not an issue weather weather
really hasn't been an issue for us
either we've had um great weather um as
far as for travel and and for tourism
there hasn't been a lot of rain there's
actually been as we all know there there
was a drought across the state um so we
had too many nice sunny days some would
argue um so weather was not um
preventing people from driving um so now
you get to the economy and uh the
economy is really where um we see the
big hit so if we look at GDP because of
the pandemic um us Bureau of economic
analysis uh real GDP decreased to uh by
31.4% in the second quarter of 2020 so
that was a big hit and it was a big hit
that happened fast the um the GDP has
Rebound in quarter three um the expected
rate has is an expected increase of
33.1% that's based on their Advanced
estimates so we'll see what that really
looks like but that's only part of the
story and so even if we have positive
price positive weather and some positive
economic uh impacts uh we need people on
the roads and so one of the things that
we look at when we project these figures
are DOT traffic numbers so the
Department of Transportation shares
their numbers with us um and we take a
look at the turnpike system um State
highways um the the interstates and and
we're seeing they're seeing a decline um
year-over-year decline of anywhere from
you know 13 to 20% um that's been
fluctuating it was real bad at the
beginning almost 50% starting to recover
but now we've got a little bit of um
fluctuation in that recovery and that's
really been the struggle that we've had
internally um and that's really the
struggle for for for anyone projecting
these gas road toll revenues where will
that Plateau happen um I was listening
into uh the Dr presentation um and the
commissioner had mentioned that um a lot
of people are are teleworking in in her
office they're working from home and
we're doing the same thing here in
safety and so part of that discussion is
as Tork becomes more normalized even
after vaccines are administered and if
we're able to move Beyond covid-19 will
less people be commuting if less people
are commuting then we'll expect less
gallonage across the state and so where
is that um where is that Gap going to be
when we compare our road toll revenues
to Prior years we originally our
projections from a few months ago we
expected that um decline to be at about
5% so we were assuming a slow and steady
increase um from now through the winter
um and eventually Landing at about 5%
you know maybe January February time
frame moving out for the rest of the
year um and what we were seeing was was
supporting that uh was supporting that
growth um Looking Back Now on where
where we are July
133% um year-over-year decline August we
recovered 1% we got to 12% September we
gained 2% we got to 10% October now
we're only 6% from October's monthly
collections from the prior year um but
November preliminary numbers just came
in the gas tax we collect that on the
20th of each month and our preliminary
November collections are about 10% off
of Prior year so we made some good gains
but we dropped back down to the 10%
range um based on all of the information
that that that I just discussed um
looking at the dot numbers looking at
our growth curve and um considering
where we think we might Plateau we moved
that Plateau percentage up from 5% to 7%
and that did result in a decline in our
estimates for road toll to bring us down
to the uh 117 million which is about
15.2 million less than our plan I have a
question for you we are currently on on
road toll
projections I have a question for you I
have my hand
up you ready yes okay so uh you you
named all the factors uh I was waiting
for you to say something about uh making
Exit 11 uh off of Daniel Webster um
tollfree do do you have an idea of how
much that decision cost the
state um I do not so this um the
revenues that we col collector for the
gas tax um in particular we call it the
road toll but the um the toll
collections are collected by the
Department of Transportation and so I
don't know what that impact would
have okay thank
you um um Steve I I think around
$600,000 was the number that we were
quoted for the loss of that uh that toll
Revenue but we could we could check it
with the we could check it with the with
the Turn Pike you Senator I think that
was that was the number and you couple
that with the other almost 1 million we
losing because of the bridge and you you
can see that uh that total revenues uh
down represent of Edwards we do have
someone from dot on the line and they
could address that for you once done his
presentation all right I'm sorry I got
confused by the Dual use of the word
toll at least I didn't think we were
talking Tollhouse
cookies no it happens it happens all the
time and um just a testament to how we
do not like taxes in the state of New
Hampshire um but essentially it's the
gas tax that we're that that we're
talking about um so then the final slide
here is the highway fund Revenue detail
listing out all the different sources um
comparing the plan to the projected uh
and showing the change um so the bottom
line for
fy21 um is really what what you want to
be focused on here so we're projecting
to collect $
239.000
million uh which is 16.4 million um less
than our plan um and that's we feel that
that's a that's a
conservative estimate not conser not
overly conservative reasonably
conservative obviously if things change
and we have additional um additional
activities on the road um the road toll
is is driving the vast majority of that
loss from plan um but unfortunately
based on all the factors that we're
seeing um we we feel like this is this
is likely where we'll end at the end of
the fiscal year and um I did provide the
committee with a version of this uh
that's not in the presentation so kind
of as a working document um which should
have the same numbers and I'd be happy
have thank you are there any
questions just just one if I might Madam
chair yes Senator Steve when is the
point in time when when the uh when the
gasoline Royal toll income that the 4
cents is dedicated to repaying the Tiffy
happen I'm sorry can you repeat the
question yes when the the Tiff loan that
we took that do took for the paving when
when does that repayment schedule begin
when we have to take all of the revenues
from the 4.1 increase in the gas tax and
dedicated
dedicated to the repayment of that loan
um Senator I don't know when that uh
when that does start I would defer that
question to uh Department of
Transportation um I just don't I I'm not
sure what the schedule is okay but but
Senator dandro this is Chris yeah Chris
somebody from do Marie Mullen is is on
the line so when Steve is done and you
have no questions related to Highway
fund we'll ask Maria to speak to your
question as well as representative
Edward's question
great just my my point is when you look
at a $15 million change in
income unless that improves dramatically
we're on a path that's going to take us
direction understood and I think part of
it is um um and again I I I I'm not
familiar with all the ins and outs of
this so I would defer to dot but what
we're looking at here are the
unrestricted road to collections only
not the restricted portion and I believe
a portion of of of what you're referring
to is part of our restricted collections
but i' I'd want Marie to speak more to
that we have Marie on the line now and
she's raised her hand if you'd like her
Oh I thought I was unmuted yes uh we we
definitely need to hear from her right
now to get this sorted out because it
sounds like the money is coming from the
unrestricted to the restricted under the
Tiffy alone okay she's on the line
now good morning I'm Marie Mullen
Director of Finance for New Hampshire do
so Senator delandro to answer your
question the Tiff
the principal payments for the tifia
loan would begin in
2025 um So currently this the the loss
and revenue we're seeing right now is
impacting the um the the commitment we
made on the loan for the rural bridge
and pavement um betterment type
expenditures so we've seen about one and
a half to $2 million decline last year
and we'll see a little bit of a decline
over what we were receiving in Revenue
back you know in
fy19 um but right now that's impacting
more on the betterment program and and
the paving and Bridge
projects um than um the principal
payments on the loan that will be in
but but there there's I mean unless
unless this situation improves uh
there's a there's a danger sign that's
up there and right now it's it reflects
in the money that we're we're giving to
the communities for for that that brid
but going
forward um unless things dramatically
improve and there's a couple of things
that are happening electric vehicles and
blah blah blah and so forth and so on
we've really got to keep an eye on this
closely I would I would
think yes um I would agree we are seeing
um changes related to fuel efficiency
that impact uh vehicle miles traveled
and the the the revenue that comes in
from the road toll as well um and as far
as the tifia payments you know we are
looking at that and looking at the
waterfall and how those revenues um
would impact and you know right now
we're still seeing that we have you know
based on future projections that we
would still have sufficient Revenue to
meet the principal payments and still
maintain the 6.8 million um state aid
Bridge uh program that's funded through
this is representative alme on does that
mean we um we're going to be paying out
maintenance no these are restricted
funds that the 4.2 cents that was passed
in 2014 those are restricted
specifically for the repayment of
principal and interest on the i93 Tiffy
alone that was uh that we received in
2016 so there's money building up in
that fund that will start to be paid out
on
Capital it it's not building up it's
actually being spent right now on
interest um on the loan and also for the
betterment program there was a a
waterfall um for that program so in the
law it first 12% goes to the
municipalities for block grant Aid then
any funds needed to pay interest or
principal then 6.8 million goes to the
state aid bridge program and anything
left over goes towards the betterment
program for Paving roads and bridges so
right now because we've deferred
principal a significant portion of that
is going towards Road and is going
towards Paving and Bridge repairs for
red lless Bridges uh that we committed
to in the Tiffy
alone so the funds AR necessarily
building up we are using those currently
to on Paving Bridges and um improving
the the roadways on our primarily our
rural roads in tier three and four
pavement so in 2025 we'll start to uh
fall behind again on those things yes so
in 2025 the majority of the funds will
be going towards paying the principal
and the funds that we going towards pay
and bridges um will not be there for
that purpose
anymore thank you representative abrami
has a
question yeah just on the same theme so
then the the grants that are going to
the the individual towns the the third
tier is the is the towns are getting
certain B rant out of this aren't they I
don't know if
I'm that's actually the first um
priority so the 12% block grant program
a portion in A and B that's broken out
based on the population and the number
of Lane miles and bridges each town and
city has in their Community that's the
first thing that comes right off the top
is that 12% before even the principal
and interest is paid so that is
guaranteed what's the the third in line
is the state aid bridge program so that
so that's for municipally owned Bridges
and with the current levels and what
we're projecting in the future we
believe that that will still be able to
be maintained with the revenues that
we're seeing we don't think that there
would be a reduction in that program in
the future based on reduced revenues not
at this point anyway so the what the
event in 2025 will not impact the grants
to the
towns no it will not yeah okay that's
what I was trying to get out thank you
you're
welcome Marie this is Chris Could you um
respond to representative Edward's
question regarding the marac toll yeah
to restate that for us if I I don't
recall at all yeah so that was uh the
elimination of Exit 11 the marac tolls
um that occurred in January of this year
and um yes the senator delandro was
correct the the net projection was a net
loss of $600,000 per year so that was
about a million dollars in Revenue and a
savings of about $400,000 in operating
costs and maintenance so that's a net of
about
$6,000 um loss to the turnpike system
6,000 or 600 I'm sorry
600,000 and and then this is
representative Edward still uh as long
as you're talking about different things
on do do you just happen to know what
the what the existing plan is Now with
uh exit 4A on Interstate 93 I I know
that's a spending issue but I'm just
curious if you know because I have
people really concerned about what we're
doing with exit
4A I do not have that plan for you but I
can follow up and get that information
um I know that the engineers and the
commissioner they've been working with
the AG's office and with other folks to
determine the best um approach moving
forward with that so I can uh look into
that and get you that information thank
welcome
well if are there any further questions
on the safety part of
this then maybe we
should continue onwards I don't know uh
Chris if you want to so you're going to
go over to Transportation now not
Transportation we're going on to
treasury okay and
um we have the commissioner for the
treasury Monica mapelli and um the
Deputy
Commissioner um Rachel Miller available
for questions Monica will be doing any
um primary answering of questions and
Rachel will assist I'm going to share my
screen with the document that came from
administrator
services and the reason I'm sharing that
is because that has the other revenue on
it which includes um the revenue for
treasury that you're you were asking
about which is abandoned property and
then interest and um interest on on the
money that we have in the state if I
could is the uh line 29 interest surplus
funds the
treasury interest that we're talking
about yes so line 11 is the abandoned
property and line 29 would include um
the interest that treasury would account
for right and I believe Monica and
you Rachel is um connected by phone so
if you need to unmute Rachel it's star
six
good
afternoon can you hear me we
can great good afternoon uh Madame chair
um members of the committee um Monica
mapelli commissioner of the
treasury and um I don't have a a a real
presentation for you happy to answer
questions um basically what I what I can
share with you today is um
the story is the same that I um
presented to you I think it was back in
May uh for abandoned property um
our our estimates haven't changed for
fiscal year 21 those remain the same
because we really don't know um what
could change until um it is uh the
spring time frame when we um when we
start liquidating um our security so
that's when we know if our if our you
know how our revenue is going to be so
the um the unclaimed property as you may
recall is is property that we have we've
have we we have not been able to return
in a period of three years so it's
property that we have received that has
been reported to us and we have not been
able to return to the rightful owner and
so the only variable we we have most of
the pieces and our estimates are are
based on a 10 year average so the only
variable in this estimate is is is as I
mentioned as I just mentioned the the
Securities portion is um we liqu we
liquidate the Securities that we receive
every year
and um when we do that it really depends
on how the capital markets are doing at
that time and that's what we know if we
will receive what we are thinking or we
have received
historically or if going to be something
different so in fiscal year 20
unfortunately the time that we were
liquidating our Securities it was a time
when the stock market wasn't wasn't
doing
well at this point there's really no
anticipation that you know we really
don't know how that's going to be
performing so it will really depend on
how the capital markets are doing at the
time that we we liquidate our Securities
so that's really the only variable other
other than that it really is based on
historic numbers U they're pretty
consistent year toe and and you know
again if nothing really changes with the
stock market around that time of the
year February March time frame um we
think that those estimates um uh will be
good for fiscal year
21 thank you has there there ever been
do you know any consideration of uh
liquidating the abandoned property
Securities over a period time the way
it's usually done in in
uh
brokerages either buying or liquidating
when you've got a long-term plan yeah
that that is a great question I I truly
not not sure about that um the one thing
is I know that I guess what I know is
that this has been the way is we do it
as a way has been that for for for some
time and and it really is it's very
difficult we try we don't we don't time
the market so it's really difficult to
know
[Music]
um you know how the market is going to
be performing the other piece is we do
have to hold these Securities for a
period of three years so our goal is to
return those funds and if comes to the
time when it's time to to to say okay we
have not return this funds and so
therefore we can include them as part of
this cheat make calculation and that's
what we you know that's at the end of
close is supposed to be closer to the
end of the fiscal year when we when we
do this process of calculating what we
can Achi so so I think it's a
combination of um you know we really
need to hold those Securities for three
years and and and also the time that we
liquidate those funds but I guess what I
can do is is just to try to find out a
little more if if if something like that
has been considered the F I just don't
have that history um with
me I'll try to find out even if it was
just over a month it would probably
smooth this out a fair
amount because also the people that
you're returning funds to that you find
will get less if we happen to hit the
wrong day in the stock
market it's true more it's true but
unfortunately like I said it's it's very
difficult um since this is just the
timing of when those are those
Securities are liquidated time in the
market it it would be just uh you know
for this for this um for this exercise
it will be a difficult um consideration
but I know all states do consider that I
I believe maybe Massachusetts waits like
in the last recession I believe they
waited and didn't sell but that would
really confuse the calculation for you
know future years so we we thought about
it actually in in in the spring we
thought about about holding it and we
decided not to we just kept uh we
decided to continue with um you know the
way it has been done in the
past right
well spreading it over four
weeks is the safest way of avoiding
timing if you're trying to stabilize it
a little but oh absolutely so this this
what happens as we begin liquidating
Securities I think we start in February
March
in but it does take a few months so it's
not a process of one day or two it
really is is a process of several months
that this funds have being liquidated so
so it's you're right you're right it's
so it's not it's not one day it is just
a bad timing it is a period of
time thank
question sure unmute unmute yourself
thankk you for that um so when I look at
the chart there's two big numbers I mean
the 3.2 million and then down the bottom
the 4.8
million uh so let's talk with about the
postretirement U maybe I missed what you
said something about that why is that
being
912 yeah post re thank you is their
right this is that is not uh I believe
that's the ministerial services that uh
will be able to answer that question the
the only Revenue that we oversee in this
in this chart is uh the abandoned
property is cheat and and the interest
and surplus funds all right right right
okay
right but you could answer that same
question for the interest and surplus F
funds it looks like you expect zero
Revenue in this year
that is correct uh you know
unfortunately um I think I do have
better news
for definitely better news for abandoned
property uh for the interest um Revenue
we we do not anticipate Revenue um or
very little at the end of fiscal year 21
and the primary reason is uh the zero
interest rate environment um this this
zero uh zero interest rate environment
is is expected to Prevail until at least
Fisco year 23 it is just one you know
one of the pieces that you know while
trying to um help the economy um you
know this is really the the folks that
we would like you know we would like to
earn some interest um that is the um you
know disadvantage of of this process
so one of you know the interest that we
will re so it depends on the interest
rate environment and it also depends on
the the C cash balances that we have or
cash
position which also depends on the
revenue performance so as we
are uh you know we're we're monitoring
our cash position and and clearly those
levels of of decline um during the last
year we we began fiscal year 29 and and
20 with robust robust cash balances but
that obviously as the revenue has
declined you
know actually Revenue has performed
better than anticipated but um we do see
uh you know it it is not the way it was
performing in fiscal year 19 and in the
beginning of fiscal year 20 and again
those that that end those earnings are
based on those you know those cash
balances so we seeing our cash levels
and anticipating that those cash levels
will decline over time we do not
anticipate the
interest if we have any interest um
there are two two two pieces that you
know we we essentially hope to c one is
to cover the uh the banking cost we hope
to earn enough interest to cover the
banking cost and the other one is if
there's any interest left uh there are
some dedicated funds that the dedicated
funds are entitled to interest we
receive some of that and and you know
after doing all that math it it is
unlikely that we will have un restricted
Revenue um we will have interest in this
lines so that's really the story for for
Revenue thank
you I believe we hit that point once in
the Great Recession too for about a year
or so maybe
more that is correct and I believe uh in
the
past interest was not uh budgeted and I
think maybe uh we began bud in in the
last maybe last bium or maybe a little
maybe the one before
last just because of that because the
interest rate environment was low for
some time and it's it was
just it was just not something that you
know to be
conservative that number was not being
considered um in you know as part of
under Revenue so this year um so fiscal
year 21 unfortunately we reduced that
you know that that estimate based on
what we know right now and for fiscal
year 22 and 23 we're not budgeting
interest okay and that's and that's
really the story so I'll be happy to
answer you know any other question you
may
have are there any other questions for
the
treasury I'd like to ask CHR Pat I'd
like I'd like to ask Chris a question on
that but we we don't want to hold her up
but yeah maybe he knows the answer to
number 12 the line number 12 on the
postretirement or do we need to talk to
Charlie Arling house about that I think
we would need to reach out to admin
service why that number is adjusted I
can do that and then provide that to the
committee after the fact yeah but I
don't think we need a full session with
Charlie but but because that that's a
big Del I was just curious about that
one yeah no I'll I'll um send a question
over to administrative services to ask
why that went down and and then I'll
provide the response back to the um
participants of this meeting okay thank
you and and in in the questions answered
that you're going to put up on the
website as
well yes yeah anything that we get after
this meeting we'll put up on the
website great thank you very much Monica
my pleasure thank
you I think
we see you on organization
day yes indeed thank you
you so your next your next agency is um
insurance and you have the
commissioner um and Norma Stallings that
will be I believe speaking to the um
sheet you should have a screen share I
think of of the presentation yes it's
already up yep okay good so I got that
right um so I think um right bringing
the commissioner in and and um nor
Stallings
meeting and I commissioner you're um
ready to go at your leisure uh thanks
Chris uh for those of you who don't know
me I I think we met most uh in May or
June we did this last Chris commissioner
Chris nicolopoulos I am joined with uh
Norma Stallings uh and a new colleague
of hers Amy doam should be on the call
and my assistant commissioner Christy
rice will be here I will turn over much
of the presentation to Norma but I'm
happy to stay on uh in case there are
any questions um or discussions we need
to
wrong hey hey Chris if I if I might
Chris how are you good thanks I was just
talking to the insurance commission of
Kansas she said she had a meeting with
you we had a great meeting a couple of
uh I guess it's two weeks ago she's
she's a terrific lady and a good friend
oh nice she's also running for the
executive committee of uh of neic and so
it'll be interesting to see her go
through that process over the next
couple months good well please uh I'll
be in touch with her but if if you I'll
give her please give her my best I will
thank you Senator thank you
Chris thank you we don't seem to have
Norma okay am I now on are yes okay I
know good afternoon
okay uh for the insurance revenues we
had originally projected
$13.9
million we adjusted that back in the end
of May to reflect the changes that
impacted from
the T paybacks and the workers comp and
also from the shift of the healthc Care
premium from the Marketplace to the
granted Advantage Health
Plan
so those factors are still in play for
what our projections are we have
realized a $2
million uh favorable variance in our fee
revenue and that's comprised of the fees
from the
agents producers the sellers of the
insurance and adjusters
licenses there were over uh
13,000 new adjusters and producers and I
think that that Revenue was primarily a
timing difference that they were got
licensed earlier on in the year as
compared to previous years
so I don't believe that going through
the rest of the fiscal year that that $2
million will you know be in excess I
think that that amount will be uh
absorbed in the renewals and we'll still
be at the uh fees originally projected
at uh 18 million as we uh updated in May
so and and on the current side of things
the uh Property and Casualty
actuary he looked at the numbers and we
did some slight adjustments but they
were not Material the factors that he
did bring into the conversation was the
homeowners and commercial rates are
rising the increase in homeowners is
combined with increases of property
value
vales and and some of those increases
are Revenue similar to before the
recession at this time the question was
regarding the wildfires in flooding that
has been uh occurring in other
states uh we do not believe that any of
that will have a noticeable impact on
the New Hampshire market now obviously
if we do experience some
flooding that that kind of changes how
things will go
but it will be won't occur until the
calendar year
2021 so that wouldn't impact until
2022 could I ask about that one on I was
under the impression that being
insurance that the companies were
spreading the risk over at least entire
countries they aren't they're doing it
state by
state that's probably a commissioner's
answer uh I certainly there are a lot of
national players uh Super Regional uh
and National players make up the vast
majority of the market but the taxes uh
that they're paying for insurance
premium tax are net premium levels and
not profit levels so even
um even in years where there are higher
losses or combined ratios uh the premium
tax calculation will be the same what we
tend to see is uh in subsequent years of
big catastrophic losses um we tend to
see companies limit their risks in
certain marketplaces which then drives
potentially will drive rates up less
competition um but I don't think for our
uh Revenue estimates they'll be impacted
losses so they don't raise the premiums
for
everybody they only do it in the market
where the disaster
occurred I think there is some premium
impact when there are big losses that
everybody feels but these companies are
sophisticated and what they try to do is
they try to spread out their risk so
if if they have uh Too much exposure on
the coast or Too much exposure in
wildfires you may see them uh become
more competitive in other markets where
they think it balances out the risk um
and less competitive or withdraw from
markets where they're uh where they have
risk thank you thank
insurance and it's all changing too yeah
the okay and as far as the uh
Health
premiums the obviously we a number of
uncertainties going in into the the 2021
calendar year because again our revenue
for fiscal year 2021 is based off of the
premiums paid paid for calendar year
2020 and we're just about at the end of
that so
the new premiums that have been approved
for calendar year
2021 actually impact fiscal year
2022 and as part of that they there were
uh some decreases in the the premium for
New Hampshire and there are obviously
other during 2020 many of the insurance
companies provided some kind of Premium
relief or some kind of a cost
sharing and we also saw movement from
the U General market the employers paid
coverage to the Granite State Advantage
plan and also the the standard Medica
aid but at this time
we still feel that the 128. two million
and that's basically the information
time are there any questions
or when when the insurers provide
premium relief provided uh or waved C
cost sharing I don't think that one
would reduce the premium tax but what
would providing premium relief after
they've put out the policy in charge the
tax yes that it
should but again what ends up happening
is some of the people on the individual
basis they may take a higher
deductible
policy but again we're at the end I I
believe there was some uh shift between
the
employers coverage and individuals that
may have gone onto uh other coverage
whether it was Cobra whether it was the
individual Market that they obtained
coverage
in just to follow up on that
representative um we in the spring we
saw a number of Auto insurers offer
premium rebates to uh to their insurance
because they weren't driving there were
there were less claims um there there
would be a modest impact um potentially
to premium tax collections based on that
um but with the status of the market and
with the uh modest rate increases we're
seeing overall We Believe those are
going to offset and that there isn't an
warranted thank
questions well if there aren't
thank you very much for coming thank you
thank you and my team is going to sign
off we working on some other projects
but if anybody needs us Chris can we
just we can get back
on
great thank you
commissioner rep you now have the Liquor
Commission up and I'm gonna po I'm gonna
share their document with you as well so
you have Tina de and commissioner M on
the line and once they're done you do
have
um us Mr garland from the Department of
Justice to talk to you briefly about the
Wayfair decision information and that
[Music]
we have uh Mr Ms on the line and um
you'll be able to speak if you press
star six
Tina
um okay thank you okay thank you very
much again Joe Malikov The Liquor
Commission here and Tina deir our CFO
we're happy to be here to give you our
Revenue
update thank you on the presentation on
page two we've provided our year-to-date
Revenue at of October 31st where our
plan was 42.2 million and the actual
transfer to the general fund at 46.6
10.4% our total revenue for year to date
is 58.1 million and we've transferred
11.5 million to the alcohol abuse or to
granted advantage and that's how we come
up with the 46.6 million that's been
transferred
our total revenue the 58.1 is actually
8.3% or $9 million over prior year and
the transfer to granted Advantage is $9
million or 360% more than we transferred
last year what's not on this slide that
I didn't provide is um the transfer for
beer tax which is projected to be about
13 million in line to what we did last
three sorry oh and um we're projecting
to transfer another 7 million doll to
the granted Advantage but I'll go over
slide so on on page three we have our
year-to-date
sales okay our year-to-date sales uh uh
from through November 15 2020 our total
sales are up over last year 2.
9% or $9 million and the total gross
profit from sales over last year is 4.1%
worth the 3.8 million and the breakdown
in those categories is the retail sales
through our Outlets are up
3.7% or 8.8 million that represents
76.9% of our business our restaurant
partners are suffering through the
pandemic as we all know Nation wide here
in New Hampshire they're down
19% or $6 million and they're about 8%
of our business our grocery partners are
experiencing a nice growth during this
uh pandemic to see uh
13.2% or $5.4 million so they're up
about
14.6% and their orders for the holiday
period have been heavy as well so their
buying is strong our miscellaneous our
mixers our non-alcoholic products
through the stores are 68.2 they're up
68.2% or about
$700,000 and
they're uh 0.6% of our business and uh
based on the current sales based on the
trends that we see
currently through
2020 we're up 3.4 4% right at this point
or just a little over $1 million
11206 to be
exact you okay so on slide four we're
providing a income statement for fiscal
year 2019 to 21 so that you could see um
how the it all flows through and at the
Top If you look on column B on line one
you have our total sales which we're
projecting to be up 23.8 million or
3.1% if you go to row N I mean sorry Row
three our net sales are going to be up
33.9 million or
4.6% on row five you have our gross
profit from
sales I know it's echoing um we're
5.5% on line nine is our net liquor
profit which is our total revenue we're
projecting
146.940 million or
3.4% in our original plan we had the
transfer to granted Advantage based on
the RSA
17616 which was the 5% that needs to be
transferred based on prior years gross
profit So based on that plan number we
would actually be at
136.6 million or almost 5 million over
um prior year this would have us about
$3 million over our plan however based
on RSA 126
aa3 we granted Advantage can request
additional funds based on their
shortfall and right now they're ejecting
it needing an additional 8.5 million and
that would have our liquor transfer to
the general fund at
a8.4
million so that we're right now we're
projecting to come in at the
128.3 million with beer tax around 13.1
million and we'd be happy to answer any
questions I just jump in this is p bromy
hi I stay uh you said you said 8.5
million you mean $848,000
correct no I'm sorry I I didn't I see it
down there 8.5 million yep yep yep yeah
that's the additional transfer that
they're asking for their requesting
okay repres I do wish that budget that
the budget committee the finance
committees would put these things in the
budget and in the fiscal committee
instead of in
revenues thank
you thank you representative Edwards has
a question yeah it's more of a comment I
just want to congratulate you if that's
all right uh on line five being healthy
relative to line one it shows it seems
to indicate that you guys have some
efficiencies in your operations where
you're making U Better profits so thank
you for taking care of our
taxpayers well one factor in that too is
that this year we didn't do the uh
promotions where you spend $150 and you
get the $25 gift card um based on the
current sales and the market and the
trends uh we didn't feel that we needed
to run those
promos brings in a lot of out of state
traffic as well so we thought it would
be something at least for the past year
during the pandemic that we wouldn't run
and we're looking at whether we'll need
to run them in the upcoming fiscal year
or not depending on what happens across
Market I'm I'm going to congratulate you
for good business judgment anyways even
if you don't want to accept
it well we we appreciate it and and we
will accept it because it it clearly was
good business judgment and just being
able to analyze the market and and
recognizing that there was additional
profit there that we that we do tend to
use as a marketing tool to get people
into the state so thank you very much we
appreciate it representative me Senator
delandra had his hand up ah Senator
delandra thank you repres madam chairman
uh Joe and in company obviously kudos to
The Liquor Commission uh great pressure
from the outside world and uh that has
to be recognized the the amount of
activity that's taking place on the
Massachusetts
border is is very very significant and
it it's it's a it's a highly competitive
environment the number the numbers are
are good uh the transfer I think is very
important because on the one hand we're
we're we're we're marketing but on the
other hand there are a lot of people who
we have to take care of and I appreciate
that and appreciate the the good work
work done by the commission so uh I I
would just say uh the numbers are the
numbers you got to be commended on that
and commended on the transfer because I
think that's going to help a lot of
people also which I think is fundamental
in this business thank you thank you
very much Senator we appreciate that
thank you representative abami has a
question yes Joe um you know I know to
keep some of the small st stores closed
I know we we've been in conversation
about stratum and that that's not going
to reopen uh other these small store is
not going to open as
well is representative at at this point
uh through November we've sent out
letters to Whitefield Newport uh hover
Street and Manchester Jaffrey Strat and
Swansea are stores that won't be
reopening however we do have new stores
that we're building now in Epsom New
London and Littleton currently we have
Steel the air in those three locations
uh we have letters of intent on four new
stores exit 17 and Conquer uh a new
store in Manchester in the Gold Street
area a new store in ringe uh next to
Market Basket where we currently have a
location that'll be an upgrade from
around 8,000 square ft to just under uh
14,000 square feet and in Claremont
where we have a six 6,500 sqare foot
location next to Market Basket will be
going to around a 12,000 square foot
location there so unfortunately uh some
of the smaller stores had to close and
that's mainly because uh not not only
because of the covid but because they
don't fit the model the brand is such
that when you draw people here from out
of state they're expecting to see the 13
or 14,000 SKS that we carry and
unfortunately some of those smaller
older stores that were kind of swept up
in the pandemic don't allow that to
happen but these new stores will allow
it to happen and we'll continue to see
that any luck in uh finding a location
around the stratum area the ex location
or zest long going well we've looked in
Greenland uh We've looked at a couple of
locations in exitor uh but nothing that
we don't have a letter of intent in that
area yet but we're continuing to look
because we recognized how important that
area is and as you know we did have a a
signed lease deal there that
unfortunately uh we weren't able to ex
exercise because of uh some of the
restraints from the town of stratum and
that was really unfortunate situation
for us because that store would be open
now if it could be but we haven't given
up the fight and we'll continue to look
you know I've been trying to help as
much as I can on my end on that
one I've been trying to thank you all
Town fathers about this one but you
don't okay thank
you thanks for thanks for helping us out
and and thanks for the you know the back
and forth with us on the phone and with
the town is always helpful we we try our
best to be uh good part business
partners wherever we go and it's just
there was an unfortunate
situation okay I have to stand 100%
don't worry
thank you representative we appreciate
it okay could we get an update on how I
think it's called total Spirits is doing
I heard some rumor that they
were failing a
little uh Total Wine in Massachusetts
yeah they've uh what they've gone to is
they've changed their marketing plans
originally when they came in they they
marketed a lot of lost leader National
Brands and uh I've had this discussion
with Senator delandro quite frequently
they've gone on to marketing uh mainly
their own Brands their private label
Brands so you'll see a lot of marketing
that they do in the state now is not
comp not competing with us because
they're brands that they exclusively
carry and we're uh we're fine with that
quite frankly if they want to advertise
what I would consider off brands or
non-name brands that are their own to
get folks into their stores that's of
little or no consequence to us because
when the consumers look at their ads
it's not products that they
recognize it's the knockoff brands that
they're famous for so um we feel that
that's actually helped us in our
crossborder because you know we're a
national brand retailer so that's what
we do we don't we don't play in that
market it's a it's a highly profitable
Market but it's a it's a very volatile
Market as well so you're actually
flipping people in your stores to to off
Brands and uh you know most consumers
will try it once but they don't come
okay any more questions
about about
this looks like not thank you very
much thank you very much Madam chair we
appreciate your time thank you members
of the committee Happy
Thanksgiving you too thank
you so represent all me your last um
agency is Department of Justice Mr
Garland and he's available able to
briefly and I'm going to take the screen
share
[Music]
off so uh Mr Garland you can start um
just providing the committee an
overview absolutely that and then they
will ask you a series of questions
wonderful thanks Chris and thank you
madam chair and thank you to the
committee for having me today um I want
to start with an apology we were
supposed to have our annual report um
out a few weeks ago and I had hoped to
have it to you before today um and
that's been delayed um it's drafted it's
complete and we should have it out
sometime um either today or tomorrow or
next week but um I wanted to come and
give you an overview uh and answer any
questions you might have um uh today in
person or as close to in person as we
can um so so just a general overview of
what we're doing um to implement chapter
uh 78e which is um was send a buil to 42
the postare bill um I am the department
of Justice's uh contact person on this
the attorney general has named me to the
the committee
that um and uh I know many of you but
for those who don't know um me uh my
name is Sam Garland I'm Assistant
Attorney General here um primarily a
civil litigator um we have uh we I work
closely with the Consumer Protection
Bureau um that that the Consumer
Protection Bureau takes in most of the
um contacts that that uh reach out to us
um from the business Community from
individuals um and so I work closely
with the team down there um we have
others in the uh in the Civil Bureau
that also work on this issue um both on
the litigation side and from the client
counseling side because we do work with
with Revenue we work with um with with
uh members of the business Community as
well and Bea and so we have um we have a
a team here though though I'm the I
think I'm the face of it um in terms of
quick overview um we still have not
received a notice under chapter 78e from
another state um that is something that
we have been trying to find creative
ways to encourage states to do um and
and we have not been successful yet um
our our understanding is that the number
of states that are reaching out directly
to remote cellers in New Hampshire is
still relatively small we have concerns
that with budget crunches in other
states um that's going to change and
we're closely monitoring to to make sure
that that if there is any uptick um that
that we are focusing on what states are
doing that we are analyzing the laws of
the states that are reaching out to New
Hampshire businesses and doing um
everything we can to ensure that they
comport with the with the state and
federal constitutions and with our laws
requirements um I have received a small
number of communications over the last
year um from businesses um and from
individuals um very few of them have
been um about direct contacts from other
states I think we've had one or two um
just in the last year um on top of a a
small number um during the first first
six months the law was in effect um I
have received a number of communications
from businesses that are trying to
comply with other states laws trying to
do it um preemptively um and and we
can't provide those businesses with
legal advice but um it is very useful to
know um who is doing that um what states
they are trying to comply with um it
gives us a more of a holistic picture of
what's going on out there um and I do
appreciate that and I try to encourage
any business that that is going down
that road to reach out um I've also
received a number of calls from from
individuals um with questions related to
oftentimes when they're purchasing thing
on things on Amazon or or or otherwise
why they're being charged um sales tax
now um because that's a change that many
of the big uh facilitators like Amazon
have put into place when sales are going
to states that have sales of use taxes
um we can't again provide tax or or
legal advice but that is helpful once
more to to kind of paint a more complete
picture of what's happening within the
state um for for those of you um who are
either aware or not aware of the Wayfair
decision um some open questions that
were left uh in that case were what sort
of connect connection a seller needed to
have with with a sales tax state um in
order to be subject to collection
efforts um and uh the Supreme Court
didn't answer that question they said
physical presence wasn't necessary but
kind of left open what sort of um Nexus
in legal terms is is just you know
connection is necessary um and and
suggested that South Dakota's law maybe
maybe probably was okay but they didn't
definitively rule on that South Dakota
had a few features um including a
$100,000 um threshold for sales amounts
200 or 200 um transactions they were a
member of the um streamlined Sales Tax
Group um and they had um uh they do not
apply their law retroactively and the
Supreme Court the majority opinion
suggested those are good features those
are things that that we we like about
this law but never said they're
necessary never said they're baselines
what we've seen since um Wayfair was the
decided um a couple of years ago now was
um a a kind of Rapid I think in tax
World um movement to um implementing
some and sometimes all but often just
some of the features that South Dakota
had so um the sales tax Institute and a
number of other um online resources
keeps an update on what Nexus is is
necessary in various taxing authorities
um to be subject to their tax rules and
um Most states have gone in the
direction of um South Dakota at least
for the minimum um gross transaction um
of $100,000 and some of them have also
done the two or the 200 um individual
transactions um and that actually is in
both directions there are some states
that didn't have a minimum or had a
lower minimum that have upped it to
$100,000 there are a number of states
that had minimums greater than $100,000
that have um had gone in the opposite
direction there are a couple of outliers
um a couple big States New York and
California have kept their thresholds at
500 $100,000 or or up them to that
amount um my guess and this is just
speculation is that uh they are big
enough states with large enough Revenue
sources that it's not cost efficient for
them to go after every single um
business that may be selling at $100,000
and they've determined internally that
the cost benefit becomes worth it at at
half a million um there are um is still
one state um Kansas that has no
Threshold at all um and that has been a
point of controversy in Kansas it
resulted in a dis agreement between the
Kansas Governor and the Kansas Attorney
General um and uh but as of right now
there's been a proposal to go to
$100,000 but it it hasn't happened um
and that that is kind of the one outlier
in the other
direction um you will see um if you were
to go um and I can certainly share with
the committee um links to this um and
and they will be in the annual report as
well but if you were to go to to see
what um various states are doing you'll
see that some states have kind of staged
out their implementation of this over
time so some are already at the the
limits they're going to be at the Nexus
some are going to do it over time um but
but for the most part they are
coalescing around about $100,000 some of
them with 200 transactions um and so
those are kind of markers that are
consistent with what South Dakota had in
the Wayfair
decision um in terms of the streamlined
sales tax group we have had some
communication with them um there are 23
states that are full participants in
that group there's one state that is a
um I think an associate um member um so
that leaves 26 states that are not
members and it leaves the District of
Colombia and Puerto Rico um which are
also not members um I think the hope at
least indicated by the Supreme Court
majority in Wayfair is that more States
would join that that would be kind of a
centralized um Clearing House for for
this process um and there hasn't been
much movement at all in the two years
since the decision came down um and so
we've had some conversations with them
because 24 States is is a large
Collective audience of places that if we
could get some sort of um
acknowledgement or agreement in place
with with those States um all at once um
could potentially help our businesses
could potentially help our consumers um
we had conversations um kind of very
informal conversations early in 2020 um
but like so many things that's been
largely derailed um by the pandemic and
we're just starting to turn to turn back
to that now um the one other thing that
I wanted to provide um an update on
before um I open it up to questions was
um as as most if not all of you are
aware um something that has happened in
the tax realm recently is is we've
brought a um an original jurisdiction
action against the state of
Massachusetts um in in the context of
their attempts to collect income tax
from New Hampshire residents who were
working within New Hampshire um that was
the culmination of an effort that really
went hand inhand with the efforts we
were already making in the way Fair um
context one of the things that we've
been working on um behind the scenes and
we're hoping to to to make public and
still are in the relatively short term
is a formal position that the state of
New Hampshire through the Department of
Justice is taking on many of the things
that I've already discussed um and and
what other states are doing within the
um New Hampshire and whether that is
potentially unconstitutional or
otherwise unlawful but in order to
enforce that we would need to um be able
to clearly articulate New Hampshire
Sovereign interests and we would likely
need to enforce it at the United States
Supreme Court that's the only forum for
one state to bring a challenge against
the other another state um one of the
kind of unfortunate but unique
opportunities that has arisen during the
pandemic is um an an opportunity to test
at least our sovereignty theories at the
Supreme Court in the context of the
income tax um dispute and so a lot of
the work that we were already doing um
Advanced um when that issue came to the
Forefront um when it was clear those
taxes were going to be imposed and they
were going to be imposed um
retroactively starting to the beginning
of the pandemic um a lot of the work
we've been doing in Wayfair um
translated well into that and vice versa
we we have we developed our arguments to
a point that we were prepared to file
them about a month ago at the US Supreme
Court um and that certainly Advanced our
ability to to articulate New Hampshire
Sovereign interests and the policy
choices that we've made as a state um
which which um in many respects overlap
when you're talking about sales tax or
income tax um just the very final point
I would like to make um is um we are not
aware currently of any state that is
operating inside New Hampshire um
collecting sales of use tax or
attempting to from New Hampshire
businesses in a way that does not
comport with the law um but we again
anticipate that there there's a there's
a decent likelihood that as States um
are trying to figure out how to balance
their budgets um this may be something
that becomes um becomes a priority that
that maybe wasn't prior to the pandemic
um and and we have to keep a close look
at that and so we are continuing to
monitor um continuing to take in all
information we can um and to the extent
that you have constituents that are
asking questions about this um that have
issues with respect to States reaching
out I would encourage and ask um that
you have them get in touch with our
office it it is incredibly helpful um
the challenge of course is that we can't
always provide them ex explicit advice
or help but it is very helpful as we're
figuring out what's happening within New
Hampshire and how this is impacting the
business Community um so again I thank
you for the opportunity to be here um I
have representative Edwards has a
question Follow by representative
abami I I think he said Edwards so I'll
Plunge in so thank you Mr Garland I just
would like to make sure I understand
what sounded like um a distinction
between your early comment and your
final comment about other states and
whether or not they're uh complying with
the law you initially I thought you said
there were some states but you didn't
name any that had uh probed our
businesses in search of sales taxes that
was my understanding and then and so I
just want to understand what sounds to
be two different
statements yes thank you representative
and that's my fault um I I probably can
conflated two different things um so we
are aware um through through
confidential reports that we received
from businesses that that are
confidential under um under chapter 7 um
8e um of Communications that they've
received from from other states it's a
small number um and I and I think I can
get a list of the states for you I don't
have it at my fingertips um but uh but
it's a small number that have at least
um probed is probably a good word it may
be um an initial notice or something
along those lines I'm not aware of any
um firm collection efforts or any audits
or things along those lines but but
certainly some
Communications um th those states have
reached out uh directly to the
businesses and we find out because the
businesses share share it with us
um through through a process that that
we're um that we try to facilitate under
78e um the the other um requirement in
chapter 78e um is is a requirement that
business or that that states that are
seeking to collect um sales and use tax
from our businesses provide notice to
the Department of Justice um before they
start those sorts of inquiries um we do
not have any of those notices and so in
in one respect um I I think the states
that are that are reaching out to
individual consumers are are probably
not complying with with our law um uh it
it they they appear to be in in a small
number of circumstances that we're aware
of contacting um individual uh
businesses remote sellers within New
Hampshire um and and at least sending um
form notices um but but the larger
question um I think before we could
bring bring an action against the state
like that um in at least in the united
Supreme States Supreme Court is is what
they're doing also inconsistent with the
US Constitution because because our
ability to enforce our law um is
extraordinarily important but it's not
something that the Supreme Court is
going to take up we would have to find
another Avenue to do it um if it would
require basically a violation of the
Federal Constitution the dormant or the
com commerce clause or the due process
clause um before The Supreme Court would
entertain that sort of um action and
that's what I'm not aware of of of any
state that that is clearly violating the
Federal Constitution um particularly
given kind of the the the suggestions
but not clear directions that that the
way Fair majority put into its opinion
most of the states appear to be hewing
relatively close to those things um and
before we could take a position um you
know at the highest quarter of the land
that a state is violating um the US
Constitution um we would need to be very
comfortable that that that is something
that we have um clear standing to do um
and and I'm not aware of any state that
um where that's the case and and that's
frankly why we need more information
because we both need to get to encourage
states to the best of our ability to
contact us or um and provide us the
notice they're supposed to but we need
to be aware of of what state laws are I
mean I can do that independently and and
we do keep kind of a running updated
list on what's Happening um but we want
to make sure that that what's actually
going on on the ground comports with the
Federal Constitution as well so so I
want to thank you because that did
clarify my misunderstanding and then I
just have a followup maybe it's a yes or
a no when you hear of a state probing
one of our
businesses uh and you know the state for
sure are is the doj sending them a
letter letting them know of our state
law we haven't yet um we we have um a
letter that that is is functionally
drafted at this point it was something
that we were going to start doing um
fairly early on this year but in
conjunction with that we wanted to
release a public position statement that
um that both our businesses and other
states were aware of of kind of the
lines that we were drawing in sand um
that that really frankly just did not
get out in the way we that's another
document that we have drafted but but
didn't get finalized in the way that we
were comfortable sending out before both
the pandemic hit which and initially
took away um some resources that are now
back on this project but also before the
Massachusetts income tax thing really
came to the Forefront and provided us an
opportunity to develop many of the
things that would be in that position
statement in the context of um active
litigation so I would expect um in the
relatively short term um that that
position statement will be out and that
we will be um directly contacting States
um in kind of drawing our Line in the
Sand that they should be complying with
our law um I can tell you that in my
conversations with Revenue who who are
much more aware of um of what other
Revenue authorities are doing um they
did not seem to think High seem to think
it was particularly likely that other
states would ever voluntarily um comply
with the notice requirement but finding
a way finding ways to encourage them to
do so is high on our list of things that
that we would like to accomplish um as
part of this of implementing this law
thank you so much byebye thank you
rep representative abrami has his hand
up is it still up yeah
almost my questions were answered and
had similar questions so it when we pass
our laws is there's no one in these
other states that are paying attention
to laws of other states that's what I'm
hearing or they just decided to ignore
them they you think they're aware or
they just ignoring
them um I think there that's a question
that Revenue would probably be able to
answer a little better than me because
um usually it's the revenue authorities
in other states the equivalent of our Dr
that are that would be sending notices
and and I think would be the agency that
would be contacting our office were they
complying with the law um my my um
understanding though is that this law
caught attention among um tax kind of
the tax academics the tax um law world
and also in in state taxation law um in
a way that that they're certainly aware
of it um my guess isn't that it's kind
of a Brazen attempt to ignore our law
really what this case is about or what
this law is about more generally and
frankly what Wayfair is about and what
the income tax case is about more
generally is how sovereigns in an age
where business has done so much remotely
um both in terms of remote sell but also
you know remote workers in the income
tax context um there are no the the the
lines were you know the lines of
sovereignty are a little bit more
blurred physical presence is not a um a
clear rule anymore that may make sense
in the modern economy and so I what I
really think is happening is we are
staking our position in the law um that
that the legislature passed and the
governor signed and that we're that
we're implementing and other states are
trying to figure out how much push back
they can give us I don't think they're
doing it in way to to just ignore us or
disrespect us I think it's really as
we're trying to find where the the
proper line is in terms of Nexus and and
um and due process considerations um it
remains in flux and so I think that's
frankly where it is and that's and
that's that's something that is that
does factor into the Constitutional
considerations right the Supreme Court
would not be a forum for us to enforce
New Hampshire law but if we have a
reasonable law that states are not
complying with um that is something that
that that I imagine we could um raise in
the context of of a commerce clause or
due process um due process argument and
so um I I I am gaining uh quite a bit of
of knowledge of this area of law but we
work with outside Council that are
professional tax Council um to help us
with this and one of the refrains I
continue to hear is this is Cutting Edge
taxation law and and a lot of these
answers are in
flux followup please Susan so Sam yes
when it comes to Amazon you're saying
that Amazon is complying that platform
if you will so are small businesses that
may sell through
Amazon to them it's kind of seamless I
would imagine that the taxes are just
being collected for the states uh it's
tacked on to the bill that Amazon
charges and it's all seamless to our
businesses does that seem correct um I
that that is um I think largely correct
um there are a couple nuances to it that
I think can complicate it slightly um
first Amazon because there are you know
there are 40s something states that have
sales tax and then there are hundreds if
not thousands of other taxing
jurisdictions within States so various
counties or municipalities um it's very
tough even for some um for an entity
like Amazon to be on top of the changes
in every single potential taxing um
jurisdiction and and my understanding um
which is now a couple months um a couple
months stale probably my understanding
as of the summer is that Amazon um was
taking the position that it could not
guarantee even if it was providing this
particular service to sellers that it
was necessarily complying with other
laws um with with all of the laws that
it could be subject that the seller
could be subject to so I think it does
streamline it quite a bit but I think
that there is always that that question
um because there is no there there's
been no congressional action in this
Arena you are dealing with a huge range
of potential um taxing authorities that
may have different rules in amaz does
not want to be in a position where it's
providing tax advice um the other
complicating factor is I I understand
that Amazon and other comparable
facilitators provide a fee for that
service and so I not all sellers are
likely willing or able to pay I think
something it was something to the to the
tune of two and a half percent or
something like that to Amazon for that
service and so that that means there
could be a number of that aren't doing
it that's a different picture then okay
R him Stringham has his hand
up yeah uh thanks for coming Sam I have
a question for you if uh I was wondering
if the state has an opinion on this an
individual uh is living in Plymouth uh
working uh working at home for a
Massachusetts based business uh for
several years he's laid off where does
he file for unemployment in
Massachusetts or New
Hampshire um that's a that's a very
interesting question thank you
representative it's something that um I
once again would have to defer to
revenue ultimately on I can tell you
that in um in the course of developing
um some of our arguments and doing the
background research um for the income
tax petition that we filed back in
October that's a question that came up I
don't have a clear answer for you um I
can certainly follow up with our outside
um outside Council on that and see if I
can get you on um and I think Revenue
may actually be in a better position to
to answer that too because I know we
touch base with them um in the context
filings so
um it sounds uh I know
that that there are other facilitators
also that
are
charging to collect sales tax on I
didn't realize that they that the seller
had an option on this so it sounds
like as long as there's a
$100,000 limit on this that sellers
could say I'm never going to reach a
100,000 I'm not
paying
um but o otherwise
um there
their their limit for the cost of the
administration is going to be two and a
half
per. something which isn't something we
can take to the Supreme Court and say
it's an undue burden I
think I think that would be um a
challenge Madam chair um I two and a
half percent is a number that that comes
to mind I think with respect to Amazon
um I wouldn't hold me to that and I'm
not sure the other um facilitators which
would be companies like Etsy like eBay
like Fair um are are necessarily um I I
know part of the the complication at
least as of um the spring was that there
was no uniformity even in what
facilitators were doing which just adds
another layer of complication to this
process which makes you know burden on
our businesses but I but I do agree with
the the general thought um that if we're
going to go to the Supreme Court with
this it would probably be a commerce
clause or due process or maybe priv
privileges and immunities federal
constitutional claim that the US Supreme
Court has taken the position in the
modern era that even though there's no
other forum for one state to sue another
um it has discretion as to whether it's
going to hear a case at all um and it is
only heard in the last 60 or so years
about half of the cases that one state
has brought against the other so you
need to convince them that it is a
matter of national importance that deals
with State sovereignty I frankly think
this is an issue that that I think
Wayfair confirms that that this is an
issue that kind of checks those boxes in
the larger sense but before the state of
New Hampshire could um realistically
bring that action I think we' need to
have a pretty clear um violation of of
the Federal Constitution and and clear
operation by one state with within New
Hampshire that doesn't mean there aren't
other options and and so one thing we're
constantly thinking about is how um if
these issues arise in different contexts
with individual taxpayers with
individual businesses um before
administrative agencies um how can the
Department of Justice um ensure that
Hampshire's um interests are Vindicated
through that and and I don't have any
great answers to you about that but but
we're not putting all of our eggs in in
the US Supreme Court basket and there
may be other ways that we can um we can
enforce New Hampshire law and enforce um
you know and vindicate some of these
interests short of the Supreme Court but
that's the clearest path for us as the
state to bring bring bring an action
it's really the only path for us as the
state to bring an
action thank you and I I do um the other
states uh legislators at least as in
ncsl people who deal with budget and
taxes are obviously still regarding New
Hampshire as a thorn in the side that
they're hoping to be able to learn to
ignore so they are noticing us it's been
in tax notes several
times it has been and one thing that I
didn't provide any update on but that
does happen from time to time is we do
get press inquiries this is something
that um that has caught attention of of
groups like tax notes um of law 360 and
other trade Journal it's caught some
attention in the local press um and we
are very we try to be very Discerning in
in when and how we give comments to the
Press about this because that's largely
outside of of our role in implementing
it but but um but it is something that
when when I speak with outside Council
who are who's involved in this who's
reading all of the tax notes that come
out who who's very much aware of how
state taxation um is developing this
remains a a significant issue several
years on and it's one that I frankly not
sure we any closer to a clear answer on
than we were when the wa Fair decision
came
it thank you very much for doing this
does anybody else have any
questions brom's hand is
up oh so it is just a more of a comment
Sam you know the issue we I know we were
working on this a year or so ago was up
to what 10,000 taxing jurisdictions
we're talking about that's the biggest
problem Ian it's not just 50 states it's
it's all the counties and city taxes so
everybody little bit of a tax and not in
New Hampshire but most States the cities
have taxes Counties have taxes sales
taxes on top of and uh I you know yeah
it has to go to Supreme Court but I
think Supreme Court was has really been
crying out State uh Federal legislators
fix this will you I mean that's really
what has to happen really has to be
fixed by the by the legislature because
this is really complex I mean it really
is complex and that the Court's not
gonna they're gonna throw their hands up
again and say jeez you
know yeah I'm sorry goe to go you go
ahead no I'm done just more of a comment
than yeah I just I I've been on
still behaving since Norm has been been
not able to do it as the thorn in the
side in ncsl and I've been firmly told
that the general principle of ncsl is
that the states shouldn't have to be
told what to do by the
feds and that there is no way that
they're going to help me do something
that would get get a state a federal law
put in that would clarify all of this
because that would be telling each state
what to
do so I don't know if
CSG
is has any different position of it if
Senator delis Sandro is still online but
um that's that's the position
ncsl well I don't to to to answer your
question um I I don't I don't think CSG
has a a statement on it I haven't
haven't checked with the but I I will
check with him I'm on a conference call
with him on the 30th of of the month we
could we can talk about this
but it's a you know it's an issue that
ncsl has been on for a long period of
time every time we go to a meeting
there's a there's a proclamation that
everyone should get into the sales tax
business and New Hampshire's always been
always been against it so you know we've
been pretty consistent in our position
and uh we'll we'll see what we'll see
what happens and there there are there
are businesses in New Hampshire who do
conformed by the way and who have been
conforming for a long period of time so
that's another that's another
situation but
anyway
s says this is this is an issue that
involves
counties cities and and just uh it's
it's you know many many many many many
jurisdictions L I think and to both I
mean and everybody
really it's the solution because even
the states that tax their businesses
have the same problem we're having our
businesses their businesses are having
the same problems we are our businesses
are complying with all of this yeah you
would think that they'd want to come up
with some kind of a unified uh software
something
somewhere that would uh make it easier
for people to comply not that we want
you know but right now it's an
impossible thing for our businesses to
comply um if this would have if States
would have really pushed us but on the
same hand their their businesses and
their states have to comply to all of
these
10,000 it isn't just us for
sure yeah my only you got your hands
full that's all I can say good luck good
luck I have one one more update actually
that representative um AB rami's comment
um that that I neglected to include
before is there has been and I don't
think it's been a major movement in this
direction but one encouraging thing that
I've seen somewhat recently um is the
state of Alaska this this may be
encouraging more of a national issue un
less of a New Hampshire specific issue
because you couldn't get much further
away in terms of of the state but um but
the state of Alaska is one of the
examples that is usually held up as
having you know hundreds of different
jurisdictions it has no Statewide sales
tax but but municipality is able to do
what it wants um and one thing that that
has occurred there um uh relatively
recently is that the Alaska remote sales
tax commission um has
passed an optional um common definition
that does set um thresholds comparable
to what South Dakota had in Wayfair um
it's voluntary um but but at my last
check which was um not today but but
within the last couple of weeks there
were several dozen um municipalities in
Alaska that had signed on to it and so
there could be a movement and I'm not
saying that that you know that New York
or other states that have um
municipality or or or or um county level
taxation are necessarily going to go
this route but that is that was an
encouraging thing to see that there does
seem to be a voluntary willingness um in
a state like Alaska to try to make it
more uniform um and so that may be
something that that we see going forward
but but I agree with all of the comments
um that that this is an extraordinarily
complicated issue that that's going to
require Congressional intervention and
um and it's something that Congress has
at various points had bills in front of
it that that would that designed to
address and and they haven't really made
it anywhere um perhaps uh you know if if
things continue the way that they have
with with the pandemic and perhaps if
this is something where States become
more aggressive there may be more
movement on a national level um but but
we are here to continue monitoring we're
here to continue to to try to figure out
what states are doing and um to ensure
that if states are are crossing um you
know constitutional Lin
um we're we're prepared we're prepared
to do what what what we can to to help
here thank you Sam thank you thank you
um there's no further discussion I'm
very glad you came today thank you for
updated then um I think
we can
say on we can
adjourn Susan thank you very much for
putting this together and I appreciate
everybody being on and all of the
comments but uh it was a very worthwhile
session and uh thank you so much for
including the Senate appreciate that
very much yeah I'm really glad that a
number of you could participate and uh
Chris Jay deserves about two-thirds of
the credit with J 4 having a little uh
for putting this
together well rep me I'd have to switch
that and say Jennifer Reser deserves
most of the credit because the meeting
together is I think the most difficult
part and running it I just want to make
a comment too as well that if there's
any questions that members think of
after this meeting feel free to shoot me
an email and I can chase that for you
and and get your responses um any
questions that were asked during the
meeting um I I will email the responses
to you um as well as put it on the
website on our website great so just
wanted to put that out there thank you
Chris you're welcome yes thank you Chris
thank you Jen uh thank you Sam and thank
you everybody I'm really ni Happy
Thanksgiving everybody Happy
Thanksgiving and a the man of a thousand